[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat édition
spéciale ce matin avec de nouvelles
auditions de la commission d' enquête
sur la sphère benalla la semaine
dernière vous avez été particulièrement
nombreux à suivre sur notre antenne les
explications dont l'ancien chargé de
mission de l'elysée
alexandre benalla de nouveau visé par
une enquête judiciaire après à la
publication par mediapart d'une photo où
on le voit armée datant d'avril 2010 est
ce celle fille pris pendant la campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel macron vient
démentir les propos qu'il a tenus devant
les sénateurs on va en parler bien sûr
ce matin avant d'écouter de nouvelles
personnalités ce sont des auditions plus
techniques qui ont pour objectif de
comprendre l'organisation de la sécurité
du président pour en parler on va et
bien retrouvé à tam tran huy qui suit
pour nous ce matin à ces auditions
atteint vous êtes devant le foyer
clemenceau ce son est bien de nouvelles
personnalités plus technique je le
disais qu'ils vont être entendus ce
matin
oui ce sont plutôt des experts qui vont
nous permettre de comprendre notamment
le fonctionnement du g espère le
fonctionnement normal puisque pourrais
je dire du gspr du groupe de sécurité de
la présidence de la république
l'un et d'un des groupes fondamentaux
dont dépend la sécurité rapprochée du
président de la république on va en
savoir un peu plus sur ce mode de
fonctionnement habituel avec notamment
l'audition tout d'abord pour commencer
de michel bernard préfet ancien chef du
gspr il occuper cette fonction de 2007 à
2012 c'est à dire sous la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy dont il a été un proche
derrière pendant de nombreuses années
pour l'anecdote d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
eh bien monsieur bernard est aujourd'hui
directeur de la sécurité du psg un club
qui aime passionnément nicolas sarkozy à
10h30 on va également avoir et bien
l'audition de jean paul solet préfet
ancien directeur du conseil national des
activités privées de sécurité
on va en comprendre un peu plus comment
fonctionne ce fameux cnaps dont on a
parlé un pendant un certain nombre
d'auditions ainsi que
le professeur de criminologie alain
bauer bref plutôt des experts que des
proches de l'anc est l'esprit devrait
être donc un peu plus calme que la
semaine dernière même si vous l'avez
dire il ya eu donc ce nouveau
rebondissement la semaine dernière
autour des propos d'alexandre benalla un
sujet qui va certainement préoccuper les
esprits un des sénateurs ce matin merci
à vous thème pour toutes ces précisions
et mon invité ce matin le sénateur et
l'ère françois grosdidier bienvenue à
vous êtes membre de la commission des
lois et donc de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire
votre réaction sur cette révélation de
mediapart cela a entraîné une ouverture
l'ouverture d'une instruction d'une
enquête donc avec alexandre benalla on
le voit sur ce qu'elle fit avec une arme
est ce qu'il y à des contradictions qui
pourrait entraîner une nouvelle audition
d'alexandre benalla devant les sénateurs
oui en même temps benalla nous a menti
mais manifestement il n'est pas le seul
il nous a menti sous serment ce matin
manifestement c'est à dire il nous a
menti au moins sur l'usagé qu'il avait
des armes sur ces autorisations et sur
les distorsions montre les autorisations
et des usages mais il n'est pas le seul
à démentir donc si on fait des
procédures en par jour on doit aller
jusqu'où parce que manifestement le
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la république le directeur de cabinet le
chef de cabinet du président la
république nous ont tous menti ils ont
commencé par nous expliquer qu'à
l'action pénale à ne s'occuper que de
l'organisation des déplacements
éventuellement d'un peu de protocoles de
tout sauf de sécurité et puis après on
les a pris en contradiction avec les
faits alors il n'y a pas seulement les
déclarations des syndicats qui sont
peut-être un peu exagéré mais qu'ils
exactement le contraire puisqu'il
parlait même de barbouzes ou de milices
privées à la présidence de la république
mais il ya aussi cet arrêté du préfet de
police qui octroie qui autorise cebenna
la porter une arme pour ses missions de
protection de sécurité à l'elysée donc
on est en totale contradiction avec les
ondes et puis après des lignes de
défense
ici si elle était unique pour tous ont
tout de même bouger nous a dit après
vous comprenez pour organiser des
voyages sur les biens coordonnées
compris la sécurité puis à prendre
maintenant la coordination c'était la
coordination sagone m'efforce de
départ sur vous pourriez néanmoins
réentendre certaines personnes est-ce
utile de réentendre des gens qui nous
mentent bon
on peut toujours mais je crois pas que
ça fera beaucoup avancé je crois
qu'aujourd'hui alors gibelin de l'ordre
public à la préfecture de police de
paris avait demandé aux députés d'être
réentendu puisqu'il s'était lui-même
suivi du mi7 s'était trompé alors s est
ce que si on réentend aujourd'hui le
directeur de cabinet du président aboli
coule sur les terrains après dix ans ils
nous diront autre chose que ce qu'ils
nous ont dit qu'ils aient depuis
complètement démentie par les faits je
crois que on n'a peut-être pas plus de
moyens c'est à dire d'investigation
matériel mais quand on nous explique que
cet arrêté notre mandat monsieur benalla
qui nous explique s'occuper tout sauf de
sécurité pourquoi
l'arrêté du préfet de police fait
mention de sa mission de sécurité nous
expliqua bah je sais pas il faut
demander à la services de la préfecture
de police et la préfecture de police en
sait plus trop qui l'a fait on nous
explique qu'on a fait à la demande de
deux
en fait à la demande de l'elysée à la
demande de l'elysée quand elle doit être
écrite aurait paraît-il été verbal c'est
un coup de fil voyez rien qui tient la
semaine dernière et vous expliquer
justement les conditions dans lesquelles
il avait obtenu son port d'armes est
cotée sur l'autorisation de port d'armes
la mission de police n'est pas un
préalable à la délivrance de
l'autorisation de port d'armes il est
prévu par les textes de code de la
sécurité intérieure en espèces que peut
se voir délivrer tout fonctionnaire
exposés à des risques dans le cadre de
ses fonctions
une autorisation de port d'armes par le
préfet territorialement compétent en
l'espèce c'est le cas on a considéré la
préfecture de police à considérer que
mes fonctions étaient exposés et m'a
délivré une autorisation de port d'armes
sur la base du code de la sécurité
intérieure et gtc donc quand je dis
fonctionnaires ces fonctionnaires ou
agents publics
j'étais agent public finalement je vois
que vous ne connaissez pas si mal les
règles d'attribution des bandes armées
ça ne tient pas c'est pas s qualité de
chef adjoint de cabinet qu'il qui
pouvait avoir une âme de chef de cabinet
n'a pas le directeur de cabinet non plus
et lorsqu'ils se déplacent ils sont
toujours avec le gspr donc ça ne tient
pas il nous a dit qu'il est il faisait
même l'objet de menace personnelle mais
qui pouvait pas s'étendre sur le sujet
ça c'est inquiétant si celui qui
accompagne de président peut être
menacée non pas à cause de sa proximité
avec le président mais pour des raisons
un personnel intrinsèque gers est encore
plus inquiétant quand en fait il n'y a
rien qui tient la réalité c'est quoi
c'est qu'elle est notre intime
conviction aujourd'hui
et bien c'est qu'ils s'occuper
réellement de sécurité tous les éléments
le corrobore et et que ça risquait
d'aller plus loin puisqu'il y avait ce
projet d'autonomisation complète de la
sécurité les haines par rapport au
ministère de l'intérieur
conviction c'est ça d'ailleurs ce que
dénoncer les syndicats de police et tous
les faits aujourd'hui le corrobore alors
pourquoi le pouvoir dit pas bah oui à un
moment il est venu avec les secrétaires
avec les les attachés de presse se bat
dans les bagages de la campagne
électorale il ya eu un moment
interférences sur la sécurité
bon c'est un peu dysfonctionné on
recadre ans par autre chose alors que là
ils s'en tiennent à une ligne de
mensonges et ce petit dysfonctionnement
de l'état devient un mensonge d'état qui
a été confirmé par
les plus hautes les plus hauts
fonctionnaires de la présidence de la
république françois grosdidier terme
sera de mise il ya donc trois nouvelles
auditions ce matin on commence par le
préfet un michel bernard c'est l'ancien
chef du groupe ajustement du gspr
qu'attendez vous de ces auditions elles
sont plus techniques sur le fond et bien
sûr cessé de nous décrire exactement
confus comment fonctionne la protection
du président de république
est-ce qu'il ya par exemple des trous
dans la raquette quand monsieur benalla
qui était tard mais manifestement ça
tout le monde l'a admis et y compris
responsables de l'elysée lors des
déplacements privés
pourquoi était-il armée le j'espère
était-il présent à ce moment là ou non
dans lors des déplacements privés est ce
qu'à un moment le chef de l'état qui
possède les codes nucléaires je dirais
échappe à la protection à la
surveillance des services de sécurité
c'est le type de question qu'elle peut
peut-être répondre l'ancien patron du
gspr responsable du cnaps
le préfet celle est qui qui était
directeur alain bauer qu'il a présidée
et effectivement c'est une curiosité
monsieur benalla qui s'occupait de tout
sauf de sécurité étaient quand même
référencé au cnaps qui effectivement
tient de registre qui doit d
habilitation pour la sécurité privée
donc on a du mal à nous explique par
ailleurs qu'il n'y avait pas de sécurité
privée à l'elysée on est quand même là
devant une contradiction évidente encore
finalement de cette commission denquête
tous à leur fin
l'objectif c'est de préconiser d'avoir
des recommandations justement sur ce que
doit être aujourd'hui à la sécurité du
président bah oui parce que d'abord on
pourra que constater les totale
contradiction déclarations des
responsables publics
et puis la réalité des faits ce qui va
installer un malaise définitivement
parce que manifestement il y aura eu
mensonge d'état et donc c'est pas ça qui
rétablira la confiance des français à
l'égard du pouvoir et puis après des
conclusions mais c'est quoi qui sont
évidentes
c'est que les l'utilisation possible de
la force légitime et la protection du
chef de l'état doivent relever de force
publique police gendarmerie et non pas 2
2 de milices privées ou de sympathisants
politiques
est-ce que ça doit être réorganisée il
faut conforter et puis comme on aux
militaires ni mais on peut mais c'est
une affaire de c'est une affaire de
ministère de l'intérieur et c'est une
affaire de coordination entre la police
et la gendarmerie comme le problème peut
se poser ailleurs bien sûr que là il n'y
a aucun sujet tabou
je veux dire la ligne rouge c'est
lorsque c'est le privé où des partisans
qui sautent qui se charge de la mission
publique de protection du président de
la république tous les cas françois
grosdidier on a vu bien que ces travaux
de la commission d'enquêté du sénat ont
crispé les relations entre à l'exécutif
et la haute assemblée il ya eu cette
tribune de nicole belloubet appelant au
respect de la séparation du pouvoir la
garde des sceaux qui est finalement un
peu revenu sur ses propos c'est et hier
au micro d entraîner l écoute je me suis
contenté de rappeler les principes
constitutionnels qui est prince qui
préside à nous diverses fonctions et
actions il ne m'appartient pas de porter
un jugement sur ce que fait le parlement
que je respecte pleinement
c'est un heureux recul parce qu'il
fallait d'abord qu'elle se rappelle que
la mission du parlement et de contrôler
l'exécutif quoi ya pas eu notre
démocratie au monde où on conteste au
parlement
le droit de contrôler les services de
sécurité du pays et si on le conteste on
tombe dans dans les régimes autoritaires
la russie la turquie où d'autres donc
or c'est un recul heureux et le
parlement et singulièrement le sénat le
sénat a fait le travail de contrôle du
parlement l'assemblée nationale je sais
j'ai fait trois mandats 1c'est eu
d'abord une chambre d'enregistrement aux
ordres de la majorité quelle que soit sa
majorité même si c'est encore plus fort
aujourd'hui qu'hier et est dans cet état
d'esprit
elle ne peut pas faire librement le
contrôle c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la
commission denquête de l'assemblée a
tourné court
c'est le sénat qui jouent pleinement
leur rôle de contrôle de l'exécutif qui
qui qui qui doit exister dans toute
démocratie digne de ce nom
françois grenier vous restez avec nous
on va retourner devant le foyer à
clemenceau nos attentes à mme tran et
vous êtes avec le sénateur et bien les
indépendants république et territoires
de l'aveyron alain marc
oui à la marque bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions et bien ce
matin on va encore avoir des auditions
au tour de la commission de la
commission denquête bénard avait plutôt
des experts a maintenant pour comprendre
réellement le fonctionnement du j'espère
et aussi comprendre pourquoi alexandre b
n'a été enregistrée au cnls apps le qnap
ceux qui s'occupent plutôt de la
sécurité privée
il est évident que nous avons besoin
nous de tous ces éléments auraient un
petit peu plus loin deux cordes dans
l'anc est que nous venons au niveau
parlementaire
car comment expliquer que le jeu espère
qui est tout à fait fait pour organiser
pour s'assurer de la sécurité du
président de la république ainsi qu'en
étant très proches il est précisé qu ont
été rapprochés du prix jeune république
ait pu être un petit peu court circuiter
pour le moins c'est ce que nous avons
entendu des divers intervenants
et comment donc monsieur benalla at il
pu approcher d'aussi près le prix jeune
république qu'il était proche du
président de république étant qu'il
était candidat
pourquoi pas mais celui ci devenu
président de république apr email 2017
il convenait de laisser complètement sa
place au j espère et de ne plus avoir
quelqu'un qui venait phagocyter ou un
petit peu court circuiter la sécurité du
président de la république et c'est ce
que nous
et oui donc là on va vraiment entendre
des experts qui va vous permettre de
voir plus clair sur ce type de situation
ça dans un contexte où quand même et
bien on a encore eu un nouveau
rebondissement hier sur l' enquête sur
la sphère benalla avec cette histoire de
photo on a pu voir alexandre benalla
avec une arme à la main prise en pleine
campagne présidentielle alors que cette
question du par damas les centrales 1
depuis le début des travaux de la
commission denquête cette question est
absolument centrale nous apercevons mois
depuis le début qu'on nous balade un
petit peu parce que on nous a dit que
cette autorisation de port d'armes c'est
monsieur vinolas lui même qui l'a dit
parce qu'il était normalement disait-il
en danger et qu'il convenait qu'ils
l'apportent lorsqu'il se rendait chez
lui et qu'il revenait de chez lui
or on s'aperçut qu'il apportait à
d'autres occasions puisque viennent de
confirmer
mediapart c'est que bien avant d'avoir
l'autorisation de port d'armes il
possédait une arme ce qui pouvait se
rêvait effectivement dangereux
on ne joue pas on ne joue pas avec une
arme même à faire des séries fille
lorsqu'au launay dans la sécurité
rapprochée de celui qui deviendra
président de la république et oui donc
en contre attaque on constate donc un
certain nombre de contradictions voire
de mensonges à ce qu'on pourrait parler
de mensonge entre les différents
intervenants on a du mal à savoir qui a
dit la vérité des mensonges je ne sais
pas en tout cas les auditions ont révélé
des contradictions et sont assez
flagrant d' entre l'autorisation de port
d'armes puisque l'autre jour nous avions
fonctionnaires éminent de la préfecture
de police qui nous a dit que ce port
d'armes lui avait été délivrée pour des
fonctions de police et que monsieur b
n'a lui même nous a dit que c'est
uniquement pour assurer sa propre
sécurité et qu'ils ne devaient porter
cette arme que pendant les trajets qu'il
eut mené jusqu'à chez lui un dernier
commentaire à la marque surtout pas très
bien ces mots qu'on a pu entendre de la
garde des sceaux
hier qui semble bien petit peu reculer
sur les critiques qu'elle avait pu faire
à l'égard de la commission d enquête
parlementaire qui dit respecter
les droits et le travail du parlement il
est heureux quand un fan l'exécutif qui
avait eu un petit peu perdu les pédales
il faut le dire puisque ils attaquaient
un petit peu frontalement que ce soit
gris vous monsieur castaner madame
belloubet il attaque un petit peu froid
demain cette commission langue est
aujourd'hui on voit que le travail qui
est mené par celle ci avec notre
président philippe bas de façon très
apaisé mais aussi très fermes et bien se
révéler assez convaincante notamment
pour révéler des contradictions dont
nous venons de parler concernant le port
d'armes
eh bien merci beaucoup à la marque
d'avoir répondu à mes questions avant et
bien ces nouvelles auditions qui vont
commencer dans quelques minutes
l'audition à suivre en direct toute la
matinée sur public sénat alors on
évoquer effectivement ce selphy qui des
ronces celle fille révélée par mediapart
hier et qui a conduit le parquet de
poitiers à ouvrir une enquête
retour sur cette photo avec elle je
m'amuse c'est une nouvelle révélation
qui met à mal l'image qu'alexandre
benalla souhaite faire passer lors de
ses prises de parole loin du jeune homme
carré et connaissant les règles de
déontologie qu'il souhaite véhiculer
mediapart révèle que l'ancien adjoint au
chef de cabinet de l'elysée s'est fait
photographier avec son arme lors de
l'entré deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle
il était alors employé par l'équipe de
campagne du candidat et la règle était
clair pour l'ancien directeur de
campagne
je peux vous confirmer que un monsieur
benalla disposait dans port d'armes dans
le cadre d' allah de la campagne
présidentielle
uniquement dans les locaux du siège de
la campagne
mais plus grave alexandre benalla a lui
même reconnu devant les sénateurs que sa
demande de port d'armes avait été
refusée pour la campagne présidentielle
sur le premier port d'armes est
intervenue une décision de frédéric
auréal chef du sdlp qui n'a pas souhaité
que je puisse porter une arme pendant
cette campagne présidentielle alors
quand ils ont découvert le cliché les
sénateurs ont eu l'impression que toute
la vérité n'a vait pas été dit lors de
son audition la semaine dernière
nous avons entendu je vois j'entends je
lis et je constate que le champ des
contradictions prospère ça démontre bien
qu'il elle qu'il aurait menti également
sur les questions relatives à son port
d'armes donc la vérité officielle de
l'elysée n'est visiblement pas une
vérité mais alexandre benalla a
davantage péché par omission que par
mensonges devant les sénateurs sur cette
question du port d'armes pendant la
campagne
pour rappel le parjure devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire est
un délit passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé ont continué à notre édition
spéciale ce matin sur public sénat à
l'occasion de la suite des auditions de
la commission d' enquête parlementaire
sur la sphère benalla avec vos nathalie
delattre merci d'être avec nous à
sénatrice et rdse de la gironde un mot
justement sur cette nouvelle enquête je
faisais ouverte hier par le parquet de
paris à la suite de la publication de
cette photo comment réagissez vous
qu'est-ce que vous je suis très choquée
je pense que effectivement nous avons
encore une fois des policiers des
gendarmes qui ont une attitude tout à
fait digne qui sont des professionnels
qui n'aurait jamais fait ça
nous ne sommes pas au far west nous
sommes pas aux états unis nous nous
offusquons à chaque fois qu'il ya une
tuerie aux états unis de cette liberté
par rapport aux armes
en france nous ne pouvons pas jouer avec
une arme a faim il aurait pu mettre en
danger la vie de cette jeune serveuse
c'est à dire que exhibé une arme si
grande sécurité n'ait pas mis on peut on
peut se faire bousculer enfin je veux
dire que voilà je pense que cela
démontre le manque de maturité et le
manque de formation c'est à dire ce
n'est pas du tout en adéquation avec le
personnage benalla qu'on nous montre qui
effectivement a suivi des cours a été
formé garde son sang froid
on voit bien que ce garçon garde ne
garde pas son sang-froid et que
effectivement cela débouche sur des
situations qui sont choquantes
françois dornier c'est vrai que ça a été
rappelée à part durable dans son
reportage
ça met aussi à mal l'image finalement
qu'il a pu vouloir transmettre la
semaine dernière aux cédants se souvient
qu'il a commencé par de longues excuses
oui mais mais mais mais mais mais tous
sonner faux pas seulement
ses déclarations tout sonnait faux même
dans les déclarations du secrétaire juin
de la présidence ou du chef ou du
directeur de cabinet c'est à dire que on
a voulu nous cacher qui s'occupait de
sécurité il faisait tout sauf ce alors
que sa formation c'était ça ses
références et ça ça il a des réelles
qualités d'ailleurs pour le faire et de
réelles compétences
sauf qu'il a une impétuosité
manifestement il a une fougue pas
canalisé or les institutions de la
république notamment la police et la
gendarmerie de les armées sont là pour
canaliser ce type d'énergie même dans
nos polices municipales quoi j'ai été
maire j'aurais immédiatement suspendu un
policier municipal qui aurait exhibé son
arme de la sorte d'ailleurs une seule
serait jamais permis pour cette raison
donc ça montre bien effectivement que le
la détention d armes et et de ne ne doit
être confiée qu'à des gens parfaitement
formés et cadrée et que notamment à
l'elysée ou pour tout usage de la force
publique
ça doit être le monopole des forces
publiques police et gendarmerie et c'est
toute la question au delà du cas benalla
de savoir si on peut privatiser et
confier en plus à des partisans à des
militants la sécurité du chef de l'état
nathalie delattre d'autant que ça a été
rappelé il ya beaucoup de contradictions
dans les propos d'alexandre benalla
est-ce que je posais la question tout à
l'heure à françois grosdidier ce que
vous souhaitez le rayon tendresse qu'il
a pu mentir sous serment
mais je crois que ça ne servirait à rien
je pense qu'effectivement il y à une
vérité officielle on l'a bien vu
on le perçoit quand on met bout à bout
les auditions voit toutes les
contradictions
donc je pense qu'à un moment donné
jamais il ne nous diront que oui il
avait peut-être besoin ce président
avait peut-être besoin d'avoir un homme
de confiance à ses côtés peut-être
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui il y a
nécessité pour un président d'être
entouré de personnes de confiance qui
sont peut-être pas des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas qui sont de la police jean
damien et enfin tout ça il faudrait
l'exprimer je crois qu'ils ne sont pas
dans le souhait d'exprimer cette chose
je pense que réécouter alexandre benalla
ne nous apporterait pas
d'autres d'autres informations je pense
que maintenant nous savons qu'il y as
par rapport à ce port d'un des
contradictions qu'il y a donc des
propositions à faire qu'il ya eu
dysfonctionnement et la justice en
tirera toutes les conséquences mais s'il
n'ya pas sûrs vous souhaitez que ce soit
suivi d'effet ça a été là aussi rappelé
par du ramier écoutez moi je pense que
on ne peut pas le nier
aujourd'hui il y à des faits il y a
effectivement des auditions il y a
cette suspicion donc je pense qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au bout des choses
les auditions on disait de ce matin vont
être plus technique françois grosdidier
est-ce qu'il faut absolument de la
transparence en ce qui concerne la
sécurité du président à ce qu'ils
faisaient de dot de la transparence
entendons nous bien on va pas tout
mettre sur la table parce que va pas
faciliter la tâche à ceux qui voudraient
s'en prendre au président république il
ya des limites à la transparence mais on
peut accepter justement à certains
secret seulement au bénéfice de force
qui respecte strictement le droit et les
principes de la république qui sont au
service exclusif de la république ait
d'aucun intérêt partisan c'est c'est
comme ça que l'on garantit la démocratie
et c'est ce qui intéresse le sénat c'est
pas la télé réalité benalla ce qui nous
intéresse c'est notre rôle c'est de
garantir le bon fonctionnement des
institutions de la république
là on avait un petit dysfonctionnement
de l'état on regrette amèrement qu'ils
se fassent transforme en mensonge d'état
ça nous met d'ailleurs très mal à l'aise
c'est pas du tout la sécurité la
protection du président de la république
et des hautes personnalités
donc nous allons entendre un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont des choses à
nous dire sur ce sujet hier mediapart a
publié une photo d'alexandre apportant
une arme alors qu'il n'avait à l'époque
pas de permis de port d'armes est ce que
ça jette le trouble sur son édition de
la semaine dernière ce que vous allez le
reconvoquer écouter pour le moment nous
avons pris acte de ses chais comme nous
prenons acte tout les jours de faits
nouveaux
je peux vous dire que nous avons écrire
monsieur
vela là pour lui demander un certain
nombre de précisions ne portant pas sur
ce sujet d'ailleurs on avait écrit
antérieurement suite à son audition dont
nous regardons les choses nous prenons
acte nous constatons que avec le temps
et avec les auditions le champ des
contradictions s'accroît il y a de plus
en plus de questions qu'ils se posent
et cela va nourrir notre rapport final
convocation sera possible tout est
possible mais ça relève de notre
décision mais tout est possible
merci voilà pour à l'intervention de
jean pierre sueur nathalie delattre on
disait ce matin les auditions sont plus
techniques il y a le préfet un michel
bernard c'est l'ancien chef injustement
du j espère qu attendez vous de cette
audition mais je pense que nous avons
effectivement besoin de mieux comprendre
le fonctionnement normal de cette
institution et puis pouvoir confronter
cette vérité officielle qui nous a été
dit avec celle de techniciens et des
sachants pour que l'on voit jusqu'où
nous nous sommes peut-être fait balader
il ya peut-être une dualité qui s'opère
et on en parlait entre le j'espère d'un
côté le commandement militaire est ce
que néanmoins il ne faut pas justement
est organisé ces questions de sécurité
autour de la présidence de la république
écoutez moi je pense que aujourd'hui oui
certainement il ya des propositions à
faire on peut juste et mais normalement
son sont des institutions qui
fonctionnent très bien ils ont une
habitude de travailler ensemble ils
s'affairent ce sont des professionnels
donc je pense que là nous avons eu un
dysfonctionnement par rapport à une
personnage particulier qui en a voulu
donner une tâche particulière et voilà
c'est un grain de sable qui est venu
dans cette institution mais je pense que
non il n'y a pas une forte
réorganisation à prévoir
le géré le dysfonctionnement c'est
monsieur benalla c'est pas la
coexistence du commandant militaire du
j'espère maintenant qu'on se dit si on a
le commandant militaire qui protège les
lieux et on a le j'espère qu'ils
protègent la personne du président
comment on articule mieux les deux c'est
un tas d'or je suppose que c'est pas
d'hier qui se posent la question
réfléchissent et travaillent tous les
jours ensemble
il peut y avoir forme de l'organisation
dur sous l'égide du ministère de
l'intérieur parce que c'est son boulot
mais au départ c'est comme ça au départ
on a eu françois mitterrand que j'ai
posé problème sa protection qui s'est
accaparé le gign qui avait pas été fait
pour ça le gign c'était pour la lutte
antiterroriste
il se des prix pour lui et après lui a
confié même des missions d'exa
téléphonique
c'était complètement de séparer sa
collection sur le prix vous avez vu avec
larmes l'autre fois j'ai sorti le nouvel
obs
pourtant sans avoir de permis de port
d'armes est ce que ça jette le trouble
sur son audition de la semaine dernière
est-ce que vous allez peut-être le
reconvoquer à sa seule ce serait très
très bien parce que là
ses réponses étaient quand même
problématique qui n'est ce pas quand je
lui ai sorti le nouvel obs il a dû en
ont mais j'avais une autorisation
allemande
on sait que les autorisations allemand
ne marche pas lorsqu'on on prend la
photo en france parce que la photo du
nouvel obs d'avril 2016 avait été plus
en france et là on a une deuxième photo
où il est et il n'a pas l'autorisation
de sortir avec son armada ça donc il ya
des incohérences il ya encore de
nouvelles choses à apprendre dans cette
affaire je ne sais pas si on va
apprendre en tout cela en tout cas c'est
à découvrir
alors peut-être nous découvrons des
nouvelles choses mais aujourd'hui je ne
crois pas que ce sera sensationnel mais
enfin on n'est pas dans le sensationnel
on est là pour détricoter une petite
affaire qui est devenue une affaire
d'état
merci à vous merci à vous savez rien
pour cette réaction de la sénatrice
écologiste esther benbassa on évoquait
justement la création du j'espère ont
rappelé sous françois mitterrand avec
christian prouteau qui était venu
justement du gie viennent pour et bien
organiser un nouveau mode de
fonctionnement de la sécurité autour du
président oui donc françois mitterrand a
pris les gendarmes du but du gène
s'accaparant veut dire ce groupe et
après le déconnectant complètement nu
ministère de l'intérieur et de l'état de
droit c'est l' affaire des écoutes et
c'est donc fort anti franc tiré les
enseignements je dis pas que la
république était beaucoup plus vertueuse
avant mais en tout cas on progresse dire
dans la construction de l'état de droit
donc aujourd'hui on a après on est passé
de la gendarmerie à la police
aujourd'hui ce j'espère qu'ils aient
mixte entre policiers et gendarmes et la
symbiose entre police et gendarmerie
fonctionne très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin d'aller
chercher des agents privés amateurs
novices néophytes quelles que soient
leurs qualités pour se substituer ou
pour les diriger c'est ça le problème
qui était posée donc on a aujourd'hui un
j'espère qui fonctionne bien qui peut
peut-être mieux s'articuler mais c'est
aux professionnels eux-mêmes de dire
avec le commandant militaire qui a la
charge des locaux et mais mais mais mais
j'insiste ça doit être une affaire de
professionnels et une affaire de force
publique qui nous garantisse l état de
droit après des dérives justement comme
celle qu'on a connue le gie viennent et
on savait très bien que il y avait le
projet de découpler la sécurité
présidentielle du ministère de
l'intérieur et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
vous êtes d'accord nathalie delattre
mecs qui vient dire françois grosdidier
ça ne va pas être déconnecté du
ministère de l'intérieur
oui tout à fait je pense
qu'effectivement il faut garantir ces
institutions il faut les poser dans le
cadre le plus serein je pense que bien
nous continuons nous ici d'exercer notre
mission cette mission de contrôler cette
mission de conseil cette mission de
proposition nous voyons bien que cette
exacerbation médiatique n'est pas de
notre fait elle est bien de la partie de
toutes ces parties qui viennent
aujourd'hui témoigner qui se
contredisent et donc je pense
qu'effectivement cela ne doit pas
dérangés ou perturber la sérénité de ses
institutions
autre audition est programmée ce matin
c'est les biens du préfet c'est les uns
et à diriger le conseil national des
activités privées de sécurité c'est le
clap si on a beaucoup parlé alors de
cette commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
là aussi qu attendez vous à ce que des
questions que vous allez poser non mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
ces institutions fonctionnent en temps
normal je crois qu'il faut rassurer les
français et que effectivement il n'ya
pas de problématique de grosse
problématique derrière il y a simplement
là ce grain de sable qui vient faire
dysfonctionnait est donc ce que l'on
veut éviter nous ce que l'on veut
proposer c'est que ce type de grain de
sable ne puisse plus pouvoir
s'interposer dans des fonctionnements et
une profession qui a besoin d'être
soutenu encore une fois reconnues laon
la discrédite une fois de plus et je
pense que pour nous c'est intolérable
c'est intéressant d'entendre les
dirigeants du club cher à la folle le
préfet celle est qui qui a été le
directeur alain bauer qu'il a présidé à
un moment et qui d'ailleurs la sécurité
privée n'a pas la prétention d'assurer
la sécurité dizaine bien au contraire et
c'est peut-être ce qu'ils vont nous
rappeler alors on pourra leur demander
pourquoi benalla été référencées au
cnaps à quel titre pourquoi pour quel
projet s'ils le savent
et eux mêmes pourront préciser les
contours et à la mort comme criminologue
de ce qu'il peut relever de la sécurité
privée qui progressent d'ailleurs en
france puisqu'on armes et il faut bien
dans sur des sites dangereux armes et
des vigiles qui sont exposées à des
risques énormes mais qui en même temps
n'ont jamais vocation à surveiller soit
l'espace public et encore moins les
institutions publiques et encore moins
la présidence de la république
la taille des lettres les auditions
touchent à leur fin et encore quelques
personnalités notamment avec des
auditions prévues la semaine prochaine
ça aura quand même mis en lumière on
disait aussi le rôle du sénat
l'importance de la haute assemblée cette
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
oui je crois que effectivement par
rapport aux français depuis des mois on
essaye de nous discréditer au sénat en
disant que c'est une institution qui
peut-être perturbent le fonctionnement
de la démocratie
on va assez loin quand même dans notre
déstabilisation aujourd'hui les français
prennent conscience de la qualité du
travail qui est fournie par le sénat et
de ses missions et de cette nécessaire
de ce nécessaire bicamérisme et de ce
contre pouvoir que nous pouvons
représenter pour le bon fonctionnement
de notre république tout simplement
alors que l'on voit sur ces images
michel bernard le préfet vient d'arriver
au sénat je voulais c'est peut-être
regagner l asala clemenceau dans un
instant on va écouter aussi votre
collègue sénatrice à muriel jourda elle
répondait aux questions et sa verrière
ogec écouter journal juste un petit mot
avant cette nouvelle série d'auditions
qu'est ce que vous attendez quel est
votre sentiment ce matin avant même le
début de ces auditions qu'est ce que
vous en attendez ce sont ce matin les
auditions j'ai pu technique de personnes
qui n'ont pas assisté à quoi que ce soit
mais qui peuvent nous donner des
renseignements
d'une part sur la façon dont la sécurité
était assurée précédemment pour un
précédent président la république était
nicolas sarkozy
et puis également des éléments
techniques sur le cnap ce sont national
des activités privées de sécurité pour
lesquelles monsieur pénale avait demandé
un agrément
bordas vous avez tous désignent pas
pas uniquement sur le port d'armes la
façon de la sécurité est assurée de
façon générale guerre mediapart a publié
une nouvelle photo d'alexandre dallas
portant une arme est ce que ça jette le
trouble sur son audition de la semaine
dernière ce que vous pourriez le
reconvoquer écoutez nous n'avons pas
discuté d'une nouvelle convocation donc
je ne peux vous donner aucune
information de ce point de vue là mais
évidemment j'ai vu l'article comme tout
le monde
voilà je n'ai pas de déclaration
particulière a fait sur cette photo j'ai
cru comprendre qu'une enquête allait
peut-être judiciaire allait peut-être se
mettre en oeuvre donc garde toute
prudence sur ce toit voilà pour la
déclaration de la sénatrice lr muriel
jourda a les auditions de la commission
enquête vont d'ailleurs se poursuivre ce
matin nous avons à les suivre en direct
sur notre antenne on va retrouver à tam
tran huy qui suit ces auditions pour
nous depuis le foyer et clemenceau temps
on disait ce sont des personnalités
beaucoup plus techniques qui sont
entendus ce matin
et oui et notamment on va pouvoir
entendre michel bernard qui a été chef
du j espère de 2007 à 2012 sous nicolas
sarkozy et dont il a été un proche
depuis des années
et d'ailleurs cette audition est en
train de commencer on va donc tout de
suite prendre la direction de la salle
clémenceau on se retrouve juste après
merci thème effectivement on l'entend
philippe bas qui s'exprime et on écoute
tout de suite la première audition de la
sécurité du paris saint germain
nous aurions certainement beaucoup de
questions à lui poser sur ce sujet qui
intéresse tous nos collègues mais nous
nous bornerons à recueillir des
informations tirées de son expérience au
groupe de sécurité de la présidence de
la république
si vous le voulez monsieur le préfet
vous pourriez mais ce n'est pas une
obligation commencer cette audition par
un petit propos liminaire avant que nos
rapporteur puis nos collègues vous pose
des questions précises mais avant cela
je me dois de vous rappeler comme je lé
fais pour toutes les personnalités
auditionnées qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission des lois doté
des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amande et je dois vous inviter à
prêter serment en disant toute la vérité
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je le jure merci monsieur le préfet
vous avez la parole merci bonjour à
toutes et à tous
vous avez souhaité même auditionné dans
le cadre de mes fonctions passées de
chef du groupe de sécurité du président
de la république
de 2007 à 2012 mais je souhaite revenir
sur ce qui a pu me conduire l'expérience
qui a pu me conduire à ce poste
auparavant
donc j'ai été officier de police pendant
21 ans de 1986 à 2007 puis en 2007 j'ai
été nommé sous préfet et en 2010 j'ai
été nommé préfet je suis donc depuis le
1er avril préfet en disponibilité à ma
demande
comme vous venez de le dire les
fonctions que j'ai pu occuper
j'ai rejoint le cercle un peu privé de
la sécurité rapprochée
en 2002 je rejoins à l'époque le service
qui s'appelait service des voyages
officiels
ce service est devenu le service de
protection des hautes personnalités par
la suite et enfin le service de la
protection aujourd'hui en 1992 pardon
j'ai dit en 2002 je crois en 1992
lorsque j'ai rejoint ce ce service j'ai
été affecté à la sécurité des
personnalités étrangères sur notre
territoire
puis en 1993 j'ai rejoint la sécurité du
premier ministre monsieur edouard
balladur alors qu'il était donc chef du
gouvernement en période de cohabitation
et candidat à l'élection présidentielle
ensuite en 2000 2002 en 1997 j'ai
rejoint la sécurité de monsieur lionel
jospin également premier ministre
toujours en période de cohabitation
également candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
et enfin j'ai été nommé à la tête de la
sécurité du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur linh nicolas sarkozy en 2000
en 2002 je suis resté chef de sa
sécurité de 2002 à 2007
donc alors qu'il a été ministre de
l'intérieur à deux reprises ministre de
finances puis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle est naturellement j'ai
été nommé chef de la sécurité du
président de la république de 2000 en
2007 et ça s'est interrompue en 2012 à
l'issue
j'ai été nommé chef de l'unité de
coordination des grands des grands
événements au cabinet du directeur
général de la police nationale et dans
ce cadre je m'occupais de l'organisation
de grands événements du type 70e
anniversaire du débarquement en
normandie comme 21 sommet européen
commémoration diverses et variées voilà
alors à quelques mots sur le groupe de
sécurité du président de la république
comme vous l'avez compris moi j'ai été
nommé chef du groupe de sécurité du
président de la république après déjà
cinq années d'expérience auprès de
nicolas sarkozy
donc c'était je dirais une voix
naturelle puisque apparemment je donnais
une satisfaction
donc j'ai été maintenu dans mes
fonctions mais cette fois auprès du
président de la république
que dire du groupe de sécurité du
président la république la
responsabilité du j'espère ce sera plus
facile à dire et bien la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
et de sa famille donc comme ans comment
cela s'entend la sécurité du président
de la république c'est une sécurité qui
s'exerce à tout moment à tout instant
qu'on soit dans des cadres officiels
comme dans le cadre de sa vie privée
quant à sa famille il est il est fait
une analyse de la menace pour savoir
jusqu'à quel niveau des membres de sa
famille cette sécurité doit s'exercer et
bien sûr c'est aussi dans le cadre d'un
échange d'un échange avec le président
de la république lui-même le j'espère à
mon époque était constitué de 90 à 100
personnels selon le moment tous ces
personnels avaient été sélectionnés par
mois ils appartenaient tous au service
de protection des hautes personnalités
ou au raid unité d'intervention de la
police nationale
concernant l'exercice de cette
protection de cette mission de cette
responsabilité je les dis elle s'exerce
à tout instant pour ce qui me concerne
pendant les dix ans pour lesquels j'ai
eu à m'occuper de la sécurité de nicolas
sarkozy et plus particulièrement les
cinq dernières années quand il était
président la république il n'y a eu
aucune exception à ces moments là
jamais le président de la république ne
m'a sollicité pour que la sécurité ne
soit pas présente à ses côtés
quel que soit le moment quelle que soit
la nature de ce moment encore une fois
que ce soit dans un homme dans un pôle à
l'occasion d'un déplacement officiel
comme alain moment à comme à l'occasion
d'un moment privé c'est un lien de
confiance qui doit s'installer avec la
personnalité sans doute pour moi c'était
plus aisée puisque je n'ai pas été
nommée à l'occasion de sa de son
élection mais bien j'ai eu à accomplir
cette responsabilité depuis cinq ans
auparavant ce qui n'a pas toujours été
le cas
deux de mes prédécesseurs de mesures de
mes successeurs
voilà c'est à peu près ce que je voulais
vous dire maintenant je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le préfet des deux
rapporteurs vous poser quelques
questions il y en a eu une très
importante que je vous posez moi même
quand vous observez les photographies et
les vidéos montrant dans un déplacement
public monsieur alexandre benalla à
proximité du président de la république
avec l' expertise qui est la vôtre
interprétez vous ces images comme le
signe qu'il accomplissait une fonction
de protection rapprochée du président de
la république pourrait tout à fait exact
j'ai vu des images bien sûr de monsieur
bénard n'a plus donné de larges
vous savez le milieu de sécurité
rapprochée c'est un milieu complexe
ils sont rentrés dans les détails on
parle de deux cercles de responsabilité
le siècle le plus proche de la
personnalité dont on a assuré la
protection est prise en compte par le
groupe bleu j'espère pour le président
la république
après on a affaire à des cercles qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus qui sont pris
en compte pas d'autres services de
police et qui constitue un filtre avant
d'arriver jusqu'au président de la
république dans le cercle le plus proche
le métier tels que j'ai eu à l'exercer
par le passé fait qu'on y retrouve bien
sûr d'autres personnes que le président
de la république sinon il serait
totalement isolé des gens à qui souhaite
rencontrer avec qui souhaitent avoir un
échange mais on y rencontre également
des conseillers qui ont par leur rôle à
avoir une proximité avec le président de
la république
et puis on y rencontre également des
gens qui fit quelques longs que l'on
retrouve tels que le préfet
territorialement compétent lorsqu'ils
accueillent le président ou
l'ambassadeur lorsqu'on a des
ambassadeurs de france lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger et c'est vrai que la sécurité
rapprochée doit composer avec ces
personnes qui rentrent dans ce cercle
quand je vois l'image
du président macron avec monsieur ban à
la proximité il m'est difficile de dire
s'il est présent à ses côtés en tant que
membre de son cabinet ou membres de sa
sécurité pour pouvoir vous répondre
il faudrait que une action se déroule à
savoir qu'il fallait opérer une
évacuation du président de la république
pour voir à ce moment là qu'ils
agiraient et que ferais tu il
aujourd'hui
la présence à proximité immédiate du
président de la république d'un certain
nombre de passes de personne ne peut pas
déterminer à coup sûr son rôle
je vous ai cité toutes les personnes qui
prouve qu'on pouvait trouver dans
l'environnement immédiat du président la
république qui rentre dans le cercle que
j'ai évoqués on y trouve aussi ce que
j'appelle moi des parasites des gens qui
sont des courtisans et qu'on trouve à
proximité de président de la république
qu eux constitue une gêne qui nous
appartient de d'évacuer parfois
d'éloigner pour pouvoir exercer cette
fonction
donc aujourd'hui je ne ne peux pas dire
sans qu'il y ait eu une réaction du
groupe de sécurité du président de la
république quel aurait été son rôle
on a des gens qui sont dans ce cercle
pour leur mission de sécurité rapprochée
et d'autres pour leur mission de
conseiller au cabinet d'autres pour deux
des missions de représentation le puits
l'autre des membres de la population qui
sont là pour pouvoir s'adresser au
président de la république donc au
premier regard il est difficile
d'identifier qui fait quoi
encore une fois il aurait fallu que
d'une action dramatique se déroule pour
pour en connaître pour connaître le rôle
de chacun merci de cette réponse très
circonstancié monsieur jean pierre sueur
juste sur ce point monsieur le préfet
nous avons eu des informations selon
lesquelles il y aurait en fait 2 sec
pour ce qui est de la proximité en radio
du chef de l'état un cercle assez large
qui est celui que vous avez décrit et un
autre le composant le comportant que
quatre personnes
celle qui exerce effectivement la
sécurité rapprochée et qui sont peu ou
titres du gspr
affecté à cette sécurité très ultra
rapprocher est ce que vous vous avez
vécu le fait qu'il y ait ces deux
cercles ou est-ce que ça n'existait pas
quand vous exercez vos fonctions que ça
a été créé depuis ce veinard la sécurité
et projet est affaire de moments
d'instants j'ai parlé de moments privés
et de moments public elle est aussi
affaire d' analyse de la menace est donc
le dispositif qui est mis en oeuvre tour
du président la république dépendent
beaucoup de cette menace est de 7,2 cet
instant ce qui est certain c'est que
quelle soupe quel que soit le j'espère
donc dont on pourrait parler c'est que
le cercle le plus proche du président de
la république est constitué de membres
du j'espère exclusivement il ya deux
siècles
alors après il y à d'autres cercles
autour il ya 1,2 alors le cercle qu'on
utilisait habituellement demande à mon
époque et je crois que c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui
il était constitué d'un triangle avec un
élément avancé un élément évacuateur est
un élément de contrôle arrière avec un
kevlar assad et un mâle est en kevlar à
sa disposition pour protéger le
président lorsqu'on était dans une
ambiance avec beaucoup de foule ou avec
une menace avérée ce triangle pouvait se
compléter d'un quart et qu'on appelait
carré tireur toujours mis en oeuvre par
le j'espère
et après on avait à faire des cercles
plus éloignés mais moi quand je parle le
cercle plus éloignées on s'attache à ce
moment-là à d'autres services de police
qui viennent participer à la sécurité du
président la république de plus de
manière plus générale et ça et à ce
moment par les services de police ou de
gendarmerie locaux qui dont le cercle
dont je parle peut aller jusqu'à un
kilomètre autour puisque le contrôle
d'accès à la salle où par exemple le
président s'exprime ou ou la salle
qu'ils visitent
il ce premier contrôle fait partie de la
sécurité du président de la république
elle vient s'ajouter ce dispositif
donc pour moi je le redis le siècle le
plus proche n'est constituée et demandé
à mon époque il n'était constituée
exclusivement de membres du j'espère il
pouvait il pouvait y avoir un deuxième
cercle technique constitué de ce qu'on
appelait un carré tireurs de susciter de
répondre à une agression
toujours constitué de membres du
j'espère et à l'extérieur d'autres
services de police ou de gendarmerie
pouvez compléter ce dispositif
merci de cette réponse monsieur le
préfet si un collaborateur du président
de la république est constamment à
l'épaule gauche ou à l'épaule droite du
président de la république dans un bain
de foule dans un déplacement dans une
rue
est ce que c'est une gêne pour assurer
sa sécurité selon les moments
cela peut être une gêne tout où l'art à
ce moment là et parfois d'utiliser cette
personne c'est une c'est peut-être des
propos qui ne sont pas tout à fait
correct ce que je vais exprimer mais une
personne qui est un obstacle
vous pouvez en faire un avantage par
rapport à l'agression dont vous pouvez à
laquelle vous pouvez avoir à faire il
vous utilisez cette personne comme un
obstacle est clairement vous ne pouvez
pas éliminer cette personne puisque le
président peut en avoir besoin
sa place peut tout à fait justifiée à sa
proximité à ce moment-là tout tout l'art
de la sécurité c'est de l'utiliser comme
un matelas
c'est la clé aussi on peut être est
impropre mais un matelas de protection
pour le président en sa faveur
le constat est que on ne peut pas les
éliminer
donc on les utilise la difficulté c'est
quand ils sont trop nombreux
à ce moment là il nous faut faire un tri
puisque il nous faut un minimum d'espacé
pour pouvoir opérer notre mission à la
fois pour intervenir et surtout pour
évacuer en cas d'agression donc cet
espace vital il est nécessaire mais il
n'a pas besoin d'être très important
donc on utilise la plupart du temps ses
membres de cabinets ou c ou ses
représentants de l'état ou ses invités
qui sont à proximité du président un
autre avantage parce qu en aucun cas
encore une fois on ne peut placer le
président de la république sous une
bulle et l'isoler totalement du monde
extérieur c'est ce n'est pas son souhait
c'est ce n'est pas notre but monsieur
sûr
puisque les hautes personnalités de
l'elysée nous ont expliqué que monsieur
benalla n'exerçait aucune mission de
police ni de sécurité puisque eux il a
été dit le devant notre commission qu'il
a pu donner des appréciations voir des
instructions à certaines personnes
relevant de des services de sécurité
serait-il crédible qu'il fût e
instrumentalisé comme obstacle le par
les véritables responsables de la
sécurité et vous ce que je veux dire
suite à votre déclaration un sommet n'a
jeu le terme instrumentalisé ne me
convient pas je vais vous parler de la
manière dont ça fonctionnait à mon
époque donner des instructions chef du
j'espère ou un membre du j'espère à
l'époque où j'étais en charge de cette
responsabilité n'était pas possible
le seul qui était habilité à le faire
c'était moi même bien sûr après je
prenais des informations du chef de
cabinet du président de la république
voire du président de la république
lui-même
je vous rappelle que cette sécurité
s'exprime à tout instant donc quand on
est un moment privé le seul
interlocuteur c'est le président de la
république lui-même pour ce qui concerne
les déplacements officiels
celui qui vous donne les informations
avec lequel se créer un échange c'est le
chef de cabinet qui alla en charge
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république donc bien sûr
il ya un échange qui s'installe avec
aller avec le chef de cabinet qui vous
doit le programme du président la
république et pour lequel vous préparez
des dispositifs plus ou moins important
encore une fois selon la nature du
déplacement selon la nature de la menace
qui pèse sur ce moment pour ce qui
concerne monsieur benalla je ne saurais
dire quel rôle le j'espère du moment
aurait pu lui donner c'est seuls eux
peuvent répondre moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que est clairement on avait
réfléchi on s'était entraîné dans cette
ancienne dans ses perspectives à savoir
le président de la république entouré
d'un certain nombre de personnes
pour pouvoir les utiliser au profit de
sa sécurité et non pas se retrouver gêné
par ces gens du fait de leur grande
proximité à l'évidence quand lorsqu'on
est mêlé dans un bain de foule et est
pour moi le de toujours deux des vingt
ans d'expérience que j'ai pu avoir dans
le monde de la sécurité rapprochée le le
salon de l'agriculture est un moment
complexe où le bain de foule peut durer
très très longtemps
c'est très pénible et là on a clairement
un moment où il ya le président de la
république souhaite avoir une grande
proximité et on a un certain nombre de
personnes qui vous accompagnent sur
toute la visite vous ne pouvez pas les
éliminer
donc vous les utiliser à votre profit
voilà je sais c'est la précision que je
peux faire mais vous abordé le cas
général du collaborateur par exemple
conseiller technique qui accompagne le
président de la république parce qu'il
est spécialiste de la matière qui fait
l'objet du déplacement tout à fait les
questions nous posons vous le savez bien
ce sont des questions un tout petit peu
différente parce que il s'agit d'un
collaborateur du président de la
république qui est autorisé à porter une
arme nous a d'ailleurs dit au cours
d'une audition publique qui lui est
arrivé de la porter en présence du
président de la république à l'occasion
de déplacements et qui avait assumé une
mission de sécurité
pendant toute la période de la campagne
présidentielle de 2016 2017
et donc ce que nous cherchons à
comprendre c'est le rôle qui pouvait
avoir en matière sécurité aucun des
conseillers qui étaient autour du
président de la république dont vous
avez assuré la sécurité n'avait de
fonctions ambiguë en matière de sécurité
il s'agissait si je comprends bien n'ont
pas de conseiller
portant une arme et participants d'une
manière ou d'une autre à la sécurité du
président de la république
oui effectivement aucun conseiller
membre du cabinet du président de la
république entre 2007 et 2012 n'avait en
charge une quelconque mission de
sécurité rapprochée
les conseillers qui pouvait être présent
auprès du président comme vous l'avez
dit l'été de par la nature du
déplacement et était là pour conseiller
et aider le président de la république
le chef de cabinet pouvait être là lui
même il le faisait d'ailleurs quasiment
systématiquement entre le lui même ou
son adjoint pour l'organisation générale
du déplacement et le lien avec les
autorités d'accueil de ce déplacement
c'est bien ça que je veux évoquer vous
savez vous je crois que pourrait tout à
fait clair il faut parler de campagne
électorale pour ma part j'ai eu à
accompagner des personnalités qui ont
toutes les trois fait des campagnes
électorales dans la perspective d'être
élu président de la république
mais à ce moment là j'ai eu à collaborer
avec des services de sécurité deux
parties des services de sécurité privés
mais en aucun cas alors que j'étais
responsable de la sécurité de 1,1
premier ministre ou du président la
république ou d'un ministre de
l'intérieur nous n'avons cédé cette
prérogative qui était la nôtre au profit
les services de sécurité mis en oeuvre
par les parties qui dépendent et dont
dépend des ces personnalités et qu'il y
avait 1
un partage qui étaient clairement
définis à savoir que la sécurité mis en
oeuvre par ces partis avaient en charge
la sécurité éloigné du déplacement du
candidat donc l'organisation de la salle
du meeting la sécurité du public la
sécurité de la scène mais la sécurité
rapprochée du candidat parce qu'il était
premier ministre ou parce qu'ils étaient
membres du gouvernement étaient toujours
de la responsabilité de la sécurité
rapprochée étatique ça ça ne faisait
aucun doute
donc ça faisait l'objet de négociations
des changes puisque bien sûr pour ce
dispositif fonctionne il faut préparer
il ne s'agit pas de se marcher sur les
pieds il faut que les responsabilités
soient clairement établies
donc moi j'ai eu la chance de de
préparer d'organiser la sécurité
rapprochée de ses trois candidats
il est vrai que si on regarde ce qui
s'était passé pour les deux derniers
présidents de la république
les deux derniers présidents de la
république ont été élus alors qu'il
n'était pas accompagné d'une sécurité
étatiques que ce soit monsieur hollande
il a été élu alors qu'il n'était pas
membre du gouvernement et monsieur macro
non plus donc
et ces deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ont eu une sécurité qui
leur a été délégué par les partis dont
il était issu et et uniquement lui si la
sécurité du candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
elle est très clairement décrites et
elle ne s'engage qu'à partir d'une
certaine dote d'une certaine date en
accord avec le camp dial candidat
lui-même et qui en fait ne correspond
qu'au quelques dernières semaines avant
le premier tour mais toute la campagne
électorale qui peut parfois être très
longue
et à ce moment là prise en charge par
décider et les sociétés de sécurité
privées ou par des militants il et quels
militants la plupart du temps ne sont
pas armés pour accompagner ces candidats
et ce n'est pas mon expérience encore
une fois moi j'ai eu à m'occuper de
trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle mais ils avaient tous des
responsabilités gouvernementales à ce
moment là le candidat nicolas sarkozy en
n'était plus ministre a à partir du mois
de février ou deux mois de mars là ça
n'a duré que quelques mois et à ce
moment là il a eu une protection de
l'état immédiate puisque c'était
tardivement qu'il a quitté le
gouvernement il a continué à avoir une
protection en nombre moins important en
tant qu'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
puisque je le rappelle tous les anciens
chefs de l'état tous les anciens
premiers ministres et des anciens
ministres de l'intérieur ont droit à
cette protection fournie par l'état dans
un nombre faible et mais la concomitance
de sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
et encore une fois son nez sa démission
est venu tardivement quelques mois avant
le premier tour a permis une continuité
de cette sécurité
même si le nombre d'agents qui étaient
désignés pour cette sécurité était
moindre
bien sûr comme quand il était ministre
de l'intérieur je vous remercie madame
jourdain
merci monsieur le président monsieur
préfet une question pour continuer sur
ce poids il nous est expliqué en
audition publique qu'en réalité il avait
été décidé que systématiquement ce
serait un membre de la chefferie de
cabinet qui se trouverait à proximité du
président de la république
s'agit-il véritablement d'un changement
ce systématisme et vous paraît-il de
nature à assurer la protection du
président de la république de république
en toute situation
ce n'était pas le cas à l'époque où j'ai
exercé la présence du chef de cabinet ou
de son adjoint à proximité du président
de la république n'était pas
systématique
elles étaient systématiques sur les
déplacements du président de la
république mais pas systématique dont
son environnement le plus proche
il accompagnait le président la
république pour faire face à tout
événement du type organisationnel en
lien avec le préfet territorialement
compétent encore une fois ou avec
l'ambassadeur de france ou avec les
autorités étrangères qui nous
accueillait mais sa présence n'était pas
toujours immédiatement à côté du
président la république
ça clairement c'est un choix du
président de la république lui-même
c'est lui qui définit qu'il souhaite
avoir à ses côtés c'est c'est une
quelque chose qui est propre à chaque
président il ne faut pas oublier que la
sécurité du président république c'est
avant tout un lien de confiance qui doit
s'installer et que et que les règles
sans être transgressée s'adapte à la
personnalité du président mais encore
une fois je tiens beaucoup à ce lien de
confiance parce que la sécurité
rapprochée c'est quelque chose
d'impalpable c'est c'est fait ou ce
n'est pas fait c'est bien assuré c'est
bien prévu où ça ne l'est pas c'est
souvent difficile à percevoir et je
crois que la plus grande réussite pour
un chef de la sécurité du président la
république c'est que le président de la
république ne pense pas sa sécurité et
que pour lui elle soit une évidence
rien qu'en vous regardent-ils c'est que
c'est tout et tout est prêt et qu'il ne
doit se préoccuper que de ce qui est son
problème son rôle premier
à aucun moment il ne doit vous posez la
question sinon je pense que il y à échec
et que le lien de confiance n'existe pas
donc la présence du chef de cabinet ou
de son adjoint à proximité de nicolas
sarkozy prêteurs de la république
n'était pas systématique parce qu'il ne
le souhaitait pas encore une fois si
d'autres dispositifs peuvent être mis en
oeuvre
je reviens ce que je vous ai dit le
dispositif de ce qui a été sa date à ces
personnes qui sont immédiatement à
proximité du président même s'il doit
être restés limités pour que cette
fonction pu s'exercer en étant dans un
petit peu la question de madame jourda
les premiers ministres dont vous avez
assurer la sécurité
je crois que l'organisation d'un
déplacement du premier ministre
ressemble un peu à celle d'un
déplacement du président de la
république surtout en période de
cohabitation
surtout en période de cohabitation ce
qui était le cas nous y dans les rues
carré
et avez vous le souvenir que dans ses
déplacements
l'organisation de la sécurité ait eu la
tenir compte de la présence du chef de
cabinet ou du chef adjoint de cabinet à
l'épaule du premier ministre pendant ses
déplacements à l'épaule systématiquement
non à proximité du président du premier
ministre oui quand je dis à proximité
à quelques mètres des quais différents
sites ce qui est différent et pour
pouvoir échanger avec lui jamais très
éloignés très bien même journal oui je
vais changer de sujet si vous voulez
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet vous nous avez déjà indiqué tout
à l'heure quelles étaient les conditions
et modalités de recrutement des membres
du j'espère je vais peut-être un peu
précises et des questions si vous voulez
bien nous répondre sur ce point du fait
de votre expérience
il s'agit évidemment de préciser quelles
sont les modalités de recrutement des
membres du j'espère etiez-vous
totalement autonome dans la sélection
des candidats s'agissait-il
exclusivement de personnes appartenant
forces de sécurité intérieure dans
quelle mesure le service de la
protection intervient-il dans cette
procédure de recrutement et et ils
systématiquement informés des
recrutements au sein du j'espère
pendant que j'ai exercé cette fonction
la totalité des membres du gspm ont été
recrutés par moi même les limites à ce
recrutement était qu'il doit elle devait
appartenir au service de protection des
hautes personnalités
aujourd'hui devenu service de la
protection ou au raid unité
d'intervention de la police nationale
il n'y avait pas d'exception quoi vous
rajoutez les fonctionnaires de les
fonctionnaires de police qui
appartiennent au service de protection
de qui appartenait aux services de
production de protection des hautes
personnalités ont tous toutes subi des
tests physiques psychologiques diverses
et variées pour pouvoir à peut
appartenir à ce service il en est de
même bien sûr pour l'utiliser
d'intervention qui est leur aide voilà
ces conditions là sont nécessaires et
suffisantes même jour doit il n'y avait
aucune émission du service de ce qui est
aujourd'hui le service de la protection
aucune immixtion dans le choix vous
recrutiez au sein de ce service mais il
y avait ni droit de veto une immixtion
dans le choix de dés des candidats il y
avait un il y avait un échange avec le
directeur du service de la protection
des hautes personnalités
mais à partir du moment où un policier
est membre du service de protection des
hautes personnalités s'est elle a
satisfait les tests donc il n'y a aucune
raison de se poser à son cou devant ce
recrutement au sein du j'espère sauf à
ce qu'il ait commis une faute
depuis son arrivée au sein du sphp ce
qui normalement aurait dû conduire à son
éviction
donc il n'y avait aucune difficulté à
pouvoir choisir au sein du vivier du
service de protection des hautes
personnalités les membres du j'espère
c'était très naturel
il a il en est de même au sein du raid
et services également par lequel on
accueille pour lequel on accède à
travers des sélections donc ce sont des
services pour lesquels il faut avoir
soumis satisfait à des tests
essentiellement physique mais pas que
pour pouvoir rejoindre ses services donc
c'est une condition suffisante pour
appartenir géo j'espère est en tout cas
c'est c'est elle que moi je les exercer
je remercie madame jourdain dernière
question les personnes qui se trouvent à
proximité immédiate du président de la
république mais qui ne font pas partie
du j'espère sont l informer de leur rôle
de matelas non ils ne le sont pas en
tant que telles elles ne le sont pas en
tant que tel mais je pense que celles
qui en ont qui en ont l'habitude ont
compris quel rôle on pouvait leur faire
jouer quand on est membre d'un cabinet
du président la république et qu'on
accompagne fréquemment le président la
république on voit bien quelle attitude
peut avoir un officier de sécurité au
plus près du président la république
quand on peut percevoir que par moments
on vous utilisent comme obstacles
toujours mais je vous remercie monsieur
sur la question monsieur le préfet
premièrement vous savez que nous sommes
dotés de nombreuses auditions maintenant
de leurs comptes rendus et donc d'un
nombre conséquent de contradictions il
nous a été dit donc monsieur benalla
n'exercer aucune mission de sécurité ni
de protection
il nous a été dit aussi qu'il exerçait
la coordination des services de sécurité
de la présidence la république
il nous a été aussi dit qu'ils étaient
soit un des membres d'une mission qui
avait pour objet de repenser les liens
qui pouvaient exister ou la coordination
qui devrait exister entre le
commandement militaire et le gspr il
nous a aussi été suggéré qu'il était en
fait non seulement membre de cette de ce
groupe de travail mais qu'il y joue un
rôle plus déterminant pour concevoir une
conception future de la sécurité du chef
de l'état est ce que dans vos fonctions
cette question tu la coordination que le
gspr et le commandement militaire s'est
posée est ce qu'il y ait eu des groupes
de travail de ce type
quel rôle jouez les représentants du
cabinet du président et je complète la
question est ce que il la zone de
chevauchement éventuel entre le
commandement militaire du play et le
groupe de sécurité de la présidence de
la présidence de la république est
tellement important que des
dysfonctionnements seraient apparus
liées aux difficultés de coordination de
ces deux entités l'une chargée de la
sécurité du palais l'autre chargés de la
sécurité du président de la république
quand il a quitté le palais monsieur le
préfet alors il est vrai que j'aurais dû
signaler que si le j'espère est
responsable de la sécurité du président
la république à tout instant ce n'est
pas vrai au sein du palais présidentiel
c'est la garde républicaine qui a en
charge cette responsabilité
c'est la seule exception j'aurais dû le
dire je m'en excuse et je m'en excuse
vis-à-vis du du commandement militaire
d'ailleurs à l'époque
moi j'avais des réactions des relations
précise très régulières parfois
quotidienne avec le le commandement
militaire avec le commandant militaire
lui-même pour bien sûr coordonner les
entrées et les sorties du président de
la république mais clairement je n'avais
je ne m'immisce est pas dans le travail
de des gardes républicains à l'intérieur
du palais l'elysée et ceux ci n'avaient
pas à connaître de mon travail à
l'extérieur du palais de l'elysée je
peux 7,7
c'est ce partage des responsabilités
était clairement établie depuis toujours
c'est un partage qui s'imposait à nous
je n'ai pas émis le besoin de le
remettre en question je n'ai jamais eu à
participer à une étude quelconque sur un
renouvellement du fonctionnement de la
sécurité du président de la république
si je veux pousser un peu plus loin mon
raisonnement
j'ai beaucoup parlé de sécurité mais il
faut aussi parler d'organisation le
j'espère en responsabilité de la
sécurité rapprochée mais aussi
l'organisation générale des déplacements
du président de la république
cela sous-entend la mise en oeuvre de
fonction j'espère de ne pas être trop
théorique mais à mon époque on était en
responsabilité de ce qu'on appelle les
cortèges donc la gestion des véhicules
du cortège présidentiel
on était en responsabilité de la gestion
de l'hébergement de la délégation du
président la république ce qui peut
représenter un grand nombre de personnes
à la logique de de la gestion des
bagages de la délégation présidentielle
en particulier lorsqu'elles étaient
élevés se rend à l'étranger de la
gestion de delà de la discipline de la
presse qui se trouve à proximité du
président la république
ce qui fait que compte concrètement
lorsqu'on a un dispositif de sécurité
on a en fait un nombre important
d'agents engagé mais on peut dire que le
nombre le plus le moins nombreux c'est
celui qui est dédié uniquement à la
sécurité rapprochée
bah on va dire de 3 à 10 selon les
moments mais ça peut être plus important
si on est dans des moments
particulièrement complexe et difficile
mais qu'on peut rapidement avoir une
vingtaine d'agents du j'espère engagés
sur des missions d'organisation générale
alors tout le monde n'entend pas cette
organisation de la même façon je crois
que vous aurez entendre d'autres
responsables
d'anciens responsables du gspm à
l'époque où j'ai dirigé le j'espère moi
j'ai souhaité prendre sous ma
responsabilité
toutes ces fonctions de manière à
pouvoir avoir une vision complète de la
sécurité du président la république pour
vous l'image et au mieux à partir du
moment où le président république
descendait d'un avion pour se rendre
quelque part
j'estimais est responsable de tout ce
qui se passait autour de lui donc ça
veut dire de la voiture dans laquelle
ils montent mais aussi du cortège de
voitures qui l'accompagnent des lieux
dans lesquels il se rend dès de la
nourriture qu'ils mangent de de l'hôtel
dans lequel il dort ou de la résidence
dans laquelle il dort mais ça s'étendait
à sa délégation puisque bien sûr un chef
de l'état ne peut pas être isolé c'est
une vision trop étroite de penser qu' on
ne s'occupe que du président de la
république la discipline la presse j'en
ai parlé aussi
on sait très bien que l'on revient dans
ces personnes qui évoluent autour du
président de la république
il nous faut les canaliser pour que pour
qu'on puisse travailler nous sécurité
pour que le président de la république
puisse se déplacer puisse avancer dans
les lieux où il doit se rendre
donc ces aspects là qui peuvent amener à
laisser penser qu'on pourrait avoir à
repenser le fonctionnement du j'espère
moi je n'en ai pas eu le besoin puisque
j'ai exercé ses fonctions conformément
avec l'assentiment du président de la
république et du chef de cabinet j'ai
mes fonctions sont allés jusque là et il
faut bien signalé que à paris et parfois
en province sur des moments très
officiel
les conducteurs sont fournies par les
gardes républicains et conduit les
conducteurs de sécurité qu'on retrouve
les gardes républicains sur un certain
nombre de cérémonies officielles pour
des dépôts de gerbes en particulier que
quelques donc il peut y avoir selon la
personnalité du chef du j'espère le
besoin peut-être de réformer celui ci
personnellement j'en ai jamais vu la
nécessité jeu je suis pas persuadé
qu'une réforme soit nécessaire moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la sécurité du
président de la république est bien
assurée malgré l'époque complexe que le
en vie je n'ai pas de doute là dessus je
vous remercie
la situation est très précises lorsque
vous étiez en poste à l'élysée avez vous
eu connaissance que d'autres personnes
que les membres du commandement
militaire et les membres du gspr que
disposer d'un et disposer d'un port
d'armes
beynat non bien sûr jamais eu
connaissance de ce type de faits toutes
les années où vous habitez en fonction
vous avez eu connaissance d'aucun or
d'armes pour aucune personne quelle
qu'elle soit appartenant au personnel de
l'elysée ou au cabinet en dehors bien
sûr de du j'ai espéré du commandement
militaire
mais non non non et encore une fois ci
ils menacent à déposer sur un conseiller
plutôt que de lui attribuer une arme on
lui a attribué une sécurité je vous
remercie
même question pour matignon
même question pour matignon même réponse
est bien et vous qui avez connu deux
cohabitations pensez vous que le
rattachement du gspr au ministère de
l'intérieur pose le moindre problème
pour le président de la république
non non je ne crois pas pour moi c'est
il ya deux forces de sécurité intérieure
en france qui sont toutes les deux
légitimes à exercer cette responsabilité
si je veux être bien complet il est vrai
que le j'espère que je dirigeais à
l'époque on était composée que de
policiers mais c'était la possibilité
qui énonçait le texte elle le texte est
bien de policiers ou de gendarmes de
militaires de la gendarmerie nationale
aujourd'hui c'est une équipe y est qui
est mixte je ne sais pas si un équilibre
entre entre ses personnels c'est pas mon
sujet les intérêts aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est encore une fois tout
en restant dans les textes la sécurité
rapprochée du président doit être
adaptée à la volonté du président la
république
est-ce que ce qui se passe au sein du
gspr et hermétique par rapport au
ministre d'intérieur autrement dit ils
informés par les membres du j'espère ou
pas le commandant du gspm des faits et
gestes du président de la république
alors pour tout à fait honnête si je
replace ça dans la situation qui était
la mienne en de rares occasions et je
vais vous indiquer lesquelles j'ai eu à
signaler des faits au ministre de
l'intérieur ou au directeur général de
la police nationale il me revient tout
de suite 2
mais il y en a peut-être quelques autres
mais ça reste l'exception l'exception a
pu se produire lorsque le président de
la république a vu un malaise lors de
son footing dans le parc du château de
versailles un mois de juillet donc bien
sûr là j'avais rendu compte
immédiatement que de ce fait au
directeur général de la police nationale
et au ministre de l'intérieur
et puis aussi lors du déplacement en
libye après la chute de kadhafi
j'avais eu des contacts avec le
directeur général de la police nationale
sur le dispositif lui-même de sécurité
que j'avais à mettre en oeuvre sur le
territoire de la libye puisque tout
simplement il me fallait faire appel à
des forces supérieures à celles du
j'espère c'est un du raid en particulier
mais aussi à des crs
vu la nature du déplacement et en
l'absence là d'un dernier ta d'aquin
pouvant nous accueillir et nous assister
dans la sécurité du président de la
république mais en tout état de cause il
est certain que je n'ai jamais rendu
compte de l'emploi du temps du président
de la république à quiconque je n'ai
jamais rendu compte du dispositif que
j'ai mis en oeuvre à quiconque
si ce n'est au président lui-même très
bien je vous remercie
alors nous avons un certain nombre de
collègues qui souhaitent poser des
questions mes chers collègues
la concision reste de mise et si vous
pouviez ne pas dépasser la
traditionnelle minute
je vous en serais reconnaissant et
surtout les collègues qui veulent aussi
poser des questions vous en seront
reconnaissants
monsieur grosdidier qui comme d'habitude
va donner le bon exemple prend la parole
en premier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet le nous expliquer d'abord que
monsieur benalla ne ne portait jamais
son arme dans les déplacements publics
mais les pouvez les porter dans son
déplacement privé d'ailleurs le
directeur du cabinet du président de
république qui est à l'origine de la
demande de port d'armes
vous expliquez que cela pouvait
contribuer à renforcer la sécurité du
président notamment dans les
déplacements privés ou la protection
était plus complexe parce que plus
allégée que dans les déplacements
publics alors on comprend mal vous nous
expliquez bien qu' il n'y a jamais
rupture dans la surveillance par le
j'espère du président de république 24h
sur 24 365 jours par an alors dans ce
cas et ça nous a été confirmé que cela
continue à fonctionner comme ça
aujourd'hui
sous ce quinquennat est ce que un
élément de l'entourage du président de
la république armée est donc d'ordre
dont la demande de port d'armes a été
d'ailleurs motivé par son rôle de
sécurité à l'elysée est-il un élément de
protection supplémentaire comme peut
l'être un matelas mais qui n'a pas
besoin d'être armé ou et peut-il au
contraire est un élément de perturbation
par un usage de l'âme qui n'est pas
forcément strictement coordonnées à
l'instant t avec les forces du j'espère
coin d'autres y était vous demandeurs
vous d'avoir un autre élément armé en
plus du gspr où était ce pour vous
plutôt un élément de
perturbations pour assurer la sécurité
du président je vous remercie de cette
question monsieur le préfet je n'étais
pas demandeur de ce type d' aide aux
j'espère le j'espère dimensionne son
dispositif selon le besoin selon
l'analyse de la menace qu'il réalise
et s'il a besoin d'être assistés ils
sollicitent d'autres services de forces
de sécurité intérieure pour savoir si
c'est une gêne une gêne ou une aide
la question qu'il faut poser c'est
participer t-il aux entraînements s'il
participe aux entraînements ce n'est pas
une jeune j'aimais encore une fois la
sécurité rapprochée affaires de réflexe
qu'on acquiert puisqu'il faut une
réaction instantanée
donc cela se travaille à l'entraînement
avec des mises en situation dans le
cercle le plus rapproché
chacun doit connaître son rôle et ça se
travaille à l'entraînement je vous
remercie madame esther benbassa aussi
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
je vais vous poser une question qui peut
peut-être paraître un peu théorique
peut-être vous saurez répondre
comment peut-on et peut-on expliquer les
missions d'une personne comme monsieur
benalla dans la production dans la
protection du président parallèlement
aux j'espère et aussi quel est le seuil
de tolérance du j'espère lorsqu'il y a
une personnalité comme monsieur benalla
jusqu'où peut aller cette tolérance
monsieur ménard je suis très gêné pour
répondre à cette question de vous pouvez
la reformuler oui et c'est monsieur
benalla était dans un bain mettez dans
la protection du président il ya le
j'espère vous nous avez parlé du
triangle vous nous avez parlé de deux
disons 2
de la gestion des différentes
personnalités et des personnes qui sont
autour du président comment se fait-il
que le j'espère laisser faire une
personne qui était quand même dans la
protection quasiment dire m en a parlé
de protection directe du président c'est
quand même ça laisse assez mystérieux
parce que le geste bella l'un des très
organisé très strictes et là on voit ce
personnage qui se promet alors on sait
pas s'il a une âme ou pas etc
alors monsieur le préfet je croyais
avoir répondu à cette question il y à
des personnalités auprès du président
qui sont incontournables
nous ne sommes pas là pour empêcher la
proximité du président la république
avec ses conseillers avec les autorités
qui l'accueille ou avec le public on
doit le prendre en compte si dans le
paysage du président la république il y
a une personnalité incontournable
nous devons faire avec encore une fois
j'aime bien faire une comparaison entre
la sécurité à la française et la
sécurité à l'américaine le sécrétaire le
secret de services interdit sécurité à
la française s'adapte c'est toute la
différence
donc s'il ya une personnalité qui est
souhaitée à proximité du président de la
république à tout instant où quasiment à
tout instant nous faisons avec nous nous
adaptons la difficulté c'est quand elles
sont trop nombreuses
mais une personnalité à proximité de lui
cela peut être le préfet qui l'accueille
sur le territoire où il sort en ça peut
être le conseiller en charge du thème
pour lequel le déplacement à court ça
peut être un interprète
ça peut être un chef d'entreprise qui
l'accueille pour visiter sa société
ces gens là existe on ne peut pas
empêcher ces gens-là d'être à proximité
de président le fait que ce soit
récurrent n'a pas d'effet nous faisons
avec
je vous remercie madame brigitte
lherbier c'est le préfet justement vous
vous prononcez le mot adaptation
s'adapte est ce que le gspr s'adapte sur
le fait ou est ce qu on a mûri il a
suffisamment de renseignements pour
s'adapter
avez-vous des réunions d'état-major à
l'avance pour dire telle personne sera
là savez-vous lors de ces réunions qui
portera une arme ou pas parce que
monsieur ben daley nous a dit que
quelques fois ils avaient larmes parce
qu'il venait directement de chez lui
donc personne ne pouvait ou pas être au
courant damman est ce que ça vous semble
normal je pense que hilton y avoir quand
même une organisé sur une âme ses
préfets alors bien sûr tous les
déplacements du président de la
république se prépare même s'ils sont
privés parfois la préparation commence
avec des réunions en préfecture
n'oublions pas qu'en france le préfet
reste responsable de la sécurité du
président de la république sur son
territoire le j'espère se pose à ce
moment là en tant que conseiller du
préfet or la bleue la plupart du temps
les préfets suivre les conseils du
j'espère puisque nous sommes les
praticiens mais malgré tout c'est lui
qui en assume la responsabilité
bien sûr nous détenons un certain nombre
d'informations et nous sont fournies par
la chefferie de cabinet quant au
programme mais également quant à la
délégation qui accompagne présent la
république nous fait nous faisons état
d'une analyse de la menace
cette menace elle est régulièrement
remise à jour de manière globale et elle
fait l'objet d'une analyse précise à
chaque déplacement officiel bien sûr ça
peut être le cas aussi pour un
déplacement privé en particulier s'il a
lieu à l'étranger
donc tous ces critères nous permet de
dimensionner un dispositif encore une
fois si le président de la république
sort du palais pour aller acheter un
médicament à la pharmacie du coin peut
lui arriver
le dispositif sera très léger très
discrets ils n'ont il en sera tout autre
lors du défilé du 14 juillet
dans le même sur le même site quasiment
c'est tout est affaire d'adaptation j'y
reviens et cette adaptation elle est
liée à aux informations qu'on détient la
na li à l'analyse que l'on que l'on peut
faire et elle s'adapte aux besoins du
président la république parce qu'encore
une fois il ne s'agit pas de le placer
sous une bulle il s'agit de lui
permettre d'exercer ses responsabilités
et d'aller au contact de la population
ce qui reste notre objectif
je vous remercie madame lherbier vous
des relances et non pas relance le mythe
ou simplement vous avez comme
information je voudrais savoir ça si
vous aviez vous avez comme information
le nom de tous ceux qui détiennent une
arme
autour du président a plus ou moins
distant que ça soit périmètre rapproché
ou plus ou moins éloignées on est quand
même dans une période de terroristes
aient compris monsieur bénard que
personne d'autre que les membres du g
spern avait une arme dans les
déplacements du président de la
république personne d'autre que les
membres des forces de sécurité à des
fonctions sécurité oui parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le cercle est troisième avec les
forces de police ou de gendarmerie
locale le sont aussi
les officiers de sécurité étrangers
lorsque le président accompagné une
autorité étrangère le sont aussi et tout
cela est clairement établie donc le nom
non mais les personnes elles-mêmes
oui et encore une fois à mon époque on
avait mis en place un dispositif
d'identification des conseillers qui
étaient sous la forme d'un pin's je
crois qu'il existe toujours un pin's
présidence de république ce qui
permettait aux agents de sécurité d'être
sûr qu'on avait affaire à un conseiller
de la présence de répliques même si
rapidement les connaît tous
mais c'est aussi une aide pour les
autorités locales qui en moins
l'habitude identifier ces personnes et
puis lors des déplacements officiels ont
mis en oeuvre il ça c'est plutôt le
protocole qui le fait d des badges pour
identifier les membres de la délégation
qu'ils soient journalistes conseiller
interprètes invités
ça permet d'identifier qui est autour de
vous et quand on est à l'étranger
le pays qui vous accueille organise les
choses de la même façon
bon dans les moments privés bien sûr
cette identification est moins certaine
mais aussi un grand
un nombre beaucoup moins important de
personnes qui gravitent autour du
président de la république dans ces
instants
merci monsieur henri leroy
mais monsieur le préfet bonjour vous
avez manifestement une expérience de la
sécurité rapprochée vous avez été
commandant de police jean était sous
préfets préfets
vous avez exercé pendant dix ans dans la
sécurité pas reprocher on peut dire que
vous êtes sorte d'expert
ma question est très simple justement en
tant qu'expert ne pensez vous pas que
quelqu'un qui se trouveraient dans la
sécurité rapprochée du président comme
c'était le cas de monsieur b dallas et
comme les syndicats de police que nous
avons entendu on dit qu'il est
terrorisée ne pensez-vous pas que
c'était devenu une gêne dans le cadre du
périmètre de sécurité pour le j espère
qu'ils sont composées d'experts qu'ils
aient qui qu'ils soient issus de la
police comme de la gendarmerie ils ont
une maîtrise des armes ils ont une
maîtrise de la sécurité par rapprocher
d'eux mêmes leur sang froid
donc ne pensez-vous pas véritablement
que c'était une gêne plutôt qu'un atout
parce que matelas peut aussi gêné les
forces de sécurité en réalité ça me gêne
plus que ça ne les arrange
et ne pensez vous pas si vous aviez été
dans ce cas que le patron du gspr a dû
en faire part au président de la
république par l'intermédiaire du chef
de cabinet ou du directeur de cabinet
sur une présence parfois permanente de
monsieur ben alla aux côtés du président
ce soit officiel dans les déplacements
officiels ou privés
voila j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis
en tant qu'expert alors on vous demande
de vous situer dans le cadre d'
hypothèse que vous n'avez pas vécu mais
comme observateur je comprends que ça
n'est pas forcément très très facile
pour vous et mai
nous demandons à bien comprendre ce qui
a pu se produire et donc je comprends la
question de monsieur leroi alesi soumaré
je ne peux pas imaginer ce qu'ont pu
être les conversations ce que peuvent
être les conversations de l'actuel chef
du gspc que le président de la
république
ce que je peux corriger dans ce que vous
avez dit d'abord c'est que je suis dans
le monde de la sécurité rapprochée
depuis 20 ans et pas dix ans et puisque
excusez moi pour la précision et
concernant le matelas je veux pas qu'on
s'attache 3,7 à ce mot je savais qu'il
pouvait générer quelques remarques
quelques réactions mais ça n'est pas un
atout on s'adapte encore une fois nous
préférons avoir les mains libres
les coudées franches mais nous nous
adaptons c'est notre rôle
encore une fois je reviens à toute la
différence entre certains services de
protection et le service à la française
notre maître mot ça reste l'adaptation
donc on fait avec bien sûr préféré qu'il
n'y ait pas d'obstacle entre le
président la république et non mais ce
n'est qu'une vision de l'esprit le
président la république seul sous un job
ça n'existe pas merci messieurs
prochaine madame jourdain une question
du président merci monsieur le préfet
lors des déplacements privés
yat-il systématiquement où il y avait-il
puisque dans votre expérience
systématiquement un membre de la
chefferie de cabinet auprès du président
oui systématiquement soit le chef de
cabinet ce soit son adjoint sur les
déplacements officiels il y avait privé
vous avez alors sur les déplacements
officiels systématiquement sur les
déplacements privés très
exceptionnellement
je vous remercie madame marie pierre de
la gontrie
merci président monsieur le préfet ma
question est simple quelques
connaissances
avez-vous aujourd'hui des fonctions
réelles qu'occupait monsieur benalla ce
préfet alors je vais parler de mes
fonctions après le j'espère après le
j'espère je les dis dans ma présentation
j'étais chef de l'unité de coordination
des grands événements au cabinet du
directeur général de la police nationale
et j'ai rencontré monsieur benalla à
l'occasion de l'organisation du sommet
orgue de décembre 2017
ce maxi dérouler sur l'île seguin sommet
pour le financement des actions de la
cote clim
pour eux pour faire un raccourci ce
sommet a rassemblé une quarantaine de
chefs d'état du étrangers et donc en ma
qualité de d'experts dans l'organisation
pour la sécurité des grands événements g
j'ai eu à rencontrer monsieur bnl à
cette occasion il était le représentant
de la présidence de la république pour
l'organisation de ce sommet il a dirigé
plusieurs réunions la auquel j'ai
assisté en tant qu'adjoint au chef du
chef de cabinet ou chargé des missions
je ne sais pas exactement mieux tout
comme adjoint du chef de cabinet il nous
fait des missions de reconnaissance sur
l'île seguin sur le bateau mouche qui
ont utilisé les chefs d'état pour se
rendre sur cette île à ses côtés et sort
son positionnement était clairement
celui du chef de cabinet du président le
chef de cabinet adjoint du président de
la république mais c'était peut-être pas
votre question
retenez reformuler la pardon
depuis le début de notre commission
denquête de nos travaux nous avons
auditionné 24 ou 25 personnes et nous
n'arrivons toujours pas à approcher de
manière extrêmement précise
les fonctions qu'occupait monsieur
benalla en matière de sécurité
vous n'êtes plus dans cette fonction là
pour autant évidemment les relations
professionnelles que vous avez le milieu
professionnel dans lequel vous exercez
aujourd'hui vous amène nécessairement
avoir connaissance de des fonctions de
monsieur benalla si elle touche aux
questions de sécurité donc j'entends par
votre réponse que vous ne souhaitez pas
répondre c'est à dire vous faites
référence je n'ai pas en cause
l'expérience que vous avez eue avec lui
parce qu'il était sans doute
effectivement chef adjoint de cabinet
pour un certain nombre de manifestations
et d'organisation mais nous essayons
d'identifier ses fonctions dans le
domaine de la sécurité avec le port
d'armes avec et et erratique et donc
c'est sur ce point là que je souhaitais
savoir quelle était la connaissance que
vous pouviez avoir de ce rôle là ce
veinard vous savez j'étais engagé
pendant 20 ans dans le monde de la
sécurité rapprochée ça ça a eu un fort
impact sur ma vie privée et j'ai
souhaité tourner la page à la fin de ma
mission auprès de nicolas sarkozy dans
la manière dont je l'exercé à savoir
reprendre une vie un peu plus normale et
je me suis fait aussi un principe de non
ingérence de nos commentaires de dvd de
la fonction de la mission de sécurité
auprès du président la république quelle
qu'elle a pu être exercées sous monsieur
hollande comme sous celle de monsieur
macron savez c'est un métier éminemment
difficile le lien de confiance est
essentielle
et tout tient ça encore une fois se met
ce métier tellement difficile que je ne
porterai jamais de jugement sur la
manière dont ce exerce cette fonction
aujourd'hui où après mois ou même avant
moi je sais que on n'a pas toujours les
coudées franches
je sais que on n'a pas toujours toute la
latitude mais après c'est une affaire de
deux personnes une affaire de relation
que le président la république et on
fait au mieux donc à aucun moment jamais
je ne porterai un jugement sur la
manière dont sont exercé ses fonctions
aujourd'hui où depuis que je les exercer
moi même je sais que vous rencontrerez
un autre chef de la sécurité du
président de la république avec un
ancien chef de la sécurité du président
de la république investi moi j'ai eu à
travailler sous lionel jospin premier
ministre
nous partageons des points de vue pas
tous et nous avons exercé une omission
de manière différente parce que nous
avions à faire des personnalités
différentes
il ya un cadre mais qui est suffisamment
large pour qu'ils puissent s'adapter à
la personnalité du président la
république je vous remercie madame de
l'autre merci président merci monsieur
préfet pour la clarté de vos propos et
et le détail de précision dans dans vos
réponses
moi j'ai deux questions vous parlez d'un
triangle d'un carré selon la pression et
le monde autour du président comment est
il recruter est ce qu'il est imposé au
président ou est-ce qu effectivement il
ya un recrutement à profil par rapport à
la personnalité du président ça se passe
comment et si effectivement cette
confiance ne s'établit pas est ce que
vous avez eu des demandes de la part du
président ou de personnalités de
changement ou même d'intégration d'un
homme de confiance qui puisse rassurer
le président est-ce que vous avez eue à
vivre cela auquel cas ce qu'on peut
s'opposer à une demande du président qui
est ce qu'un préfet de police où peut se
poser à ce type de demande ça c'était ma
première question
la deuxième c'est que vous parlez
effectivement des déplacements officiels
et des déplacements privés vous parlez
du président de la république et de sa
famille jusqu'à quel degré dans sa
famille
vallat protection là je parle de
brigitte macron une voix alexandre
benalla sur des photos autour de
brigitte macron est-ce que effectivement
c'est le gspr comme on nous l'a dit ou
alors ça a été qui couvrent
effectivement ses déplacements même
privé ou est ce que vous faites appel à
un autre cercle qui n'est pas le
deuxième sac celui de la police
nationale parce que vous manqué
d'effectif et donc vous avez besoin de
faire appel à des personnalités
extérieures
merci monsieur le préfet alors pour
l'autre le recrutement
à mon époque je ne me suis jamais fait
imposer un quelconque recrutement par
qui que ce soit que ce soit le président
de la république le ministre de
l'intérieur le préfet de police
le directeur général de la police
nationale c'est toujours moi qui décide
et de qui appartenait au j'espère dans
les limites que je vous ai expliqué à
savoir il fallait appartenir au sphp ou
au raid donc avoir satisfait aux
sélections sportif au pouvoir à part
appartenir à ces circuits à aucun moment
le président de la république ne s'est
jamais étonné de qui pouvait être à ses
côtés n'a jamais fait de remarques sur
physique sur l'attitude sur le sexe sur
une quelconque appartenance à quelle
quelle qu'elle soit de ces personnes on
en revient au lien de confiance je suis
le chef du j'espère je met en oeuvre les
dispositifs de sécurité
selon l'analyse de la menace qui est
porté à ma connaissance
selon les habitudes du président de la
république selon le contexte et je
recrute les agents qui sont membres de
ce j'espère sur lons les mêmes critères
tout d'abord au sein de deux
professionnels et ensuite en fonction du
besoin
bien sûr au sein du j'espère on peut
avoir des profils différents
vous savez pour continuer sur ce que je
dis je dis à par rapport aux
personnalités qu'on retrouve dans
l'entourage du président au sein du
groupe de sécurité il ya un agent qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon le siège on
appelle le siège parce qu'ils occupent
le siège avant droit de la voiture du
président de la république
son rôle c'est en fait de décharger le
reste
de l'équipe de sécurité des soucis qui
pourraient être ceux du président la
république à savoir le port du manteau
le port du discours le port de la
mallette voilà c'est ce genre de
préoccupations qui font que ça pourrait
être un obstacle à l'exercice de la
mission de sécurité donc le siège
il est sélectionné en fonction de
certains critères mais un évacuateur
marseille aix yonnais en fonction
d'autres critères
je vais parler de carre tireur un tireur
opérationnel va aussi être sélectionnés
en fonction d'autres critères
ça reste des critères professionnels
uniquement professionnelle il n'y a
jamais dit à mon époque il n'y a jamais
eu d'interférence dans le choix des
agents du j'espère
concernant la sécurité de la famille
lorsque le président de la république
était lui très très très rapidement on
fait une analyse de son environnement
familial pour savoir quelle menace
pesait peu pesé sur ces les membres de
sa famille et pour proposer au président
de la république
jusqu'à quel niveau de ses proches on va
assurer une protection et de quelle
manière on va l'assurer dont bien
entendu le conjoint
c'est la première des personnes à
laquelle on pense mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là pour ma part les enfants du
président de la république
sa maman était prise en compte par le
gspr et uniquement par le j'espère à ce
moment là on tombe sur des personnalités
qui subissent la sécurité qui subissent
la protection qui souvent ne la
souhaitent pas et et dans ce contexte on
a surtout affaire à des missions dans le
cadre privé rarement dans le cadre
officiel même s'il épouse du président
peut avoir des responsabilités
accompagné le président de la république
ou avoir des déplacements propres qu'ils
soient propres dans des cadres plus
officielle donc il n'y a jamais eu
quelqu'un d'autre qui ne soit du
j'espère qu'ils aient appartenu à cette
sécurité
mais bien entendu il y avait une
sécurité rapprochée qui détermine et
encore une fois en fonction de l'analyse
de la menace et puis du
de l'accord du président de la
république parce que honnêtement à mon
époque imposé à un enfant une sécurité
rapprochée ça peut être compliqué un
adolescent avec la vie qui va avec
ça peut être compliqué mais il n'a pas
choisi d'être le fils ou la fille du
président de la république ou du premier
ministre à l'époque
et malheureusement le contexte
aujourd'hui veut qu' on ne peut pas
négliger ces personnes qui à l'évidence
peuvent constituer une cible pour faire
pression sur le président de la
république donc bien sûr si son émission
qui sont prises en compte par le
j'espère et on revient sur le lien de
confiance tout ce qui se passe au sein
de la famille du président la république
doit rester du domaine confidentiel donc
il sait aussi pour cette raison que cela
reste du domaine du j'espère est
uniquement due j'espère je vous remercie
madame di folco
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet dans vos propos j'ai noté que à
votre époque
le gspr était composé de 90 à 100 agents
j'ai noté lors de l'audition du présent
chef du j'espère qu'en effectifs à 76
donc une nette diminution me semble-t-il
savez-vous quand cette diminution a été
opéré et par qui et pourquoi
et j'ai l'impression aussi dans vos
propos que les missions du gspr de votre
époque était plus large que les missions
actuelles ou en tout cas j'ai en tête
formulée différemment
il me semble que la chefferie
actuellement à des missions qui empiète
me semble-t-il sur celle du gspr alors
est ce que le fait que l'émission de la
chefferie a été accentuée voire
peut-être par l'embauché de
collaborateurs supplémentaires provient
du fait qu'il ya eu une diminution des
effectifs officiel gspr ces préfets
première partie de l'équipe de la
question c'est le nombre d'agents du
j'espère le nombre d'agents du j'espère
il a été variable selon chaque président
la république s'y regarde si on remonte
à l'époque de jacques chirac s'était on
avait une équipe mixte policiers
gendarmes a acquitté un parité qui je
crois de mémoire était de 60 personnels
mais qui était complété par un groupe
dédié à l'organisation générale des
déplacements du président la république
qui faisait à peu près une quinzaine de
fonctionnaires pour ce qui était du
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy je vous ai donné les critères
j'avais moi souhaité qu'il n'y ait pas
de distinction entre le groupe
d'organisation générale et le groupe de
sécurité du président de la république
puisque pour moi ce sont des missions
qui sont trop proches et c'est une
erreur de les distinguer selon mon
analyse
lorsque françois hollande a été élu
président la république un autre choix a
été fait à nouveau une parité entre
policiers et gendarmes avec un chiffre
qui est allé à la réduction je ne sais
plus de combien
aujourd'hui le chiffre affiché est celui
là celui que vous avez cités en fait je
ne sais pas s'il est exact ou pas je ne
peux qu une fois j'ai que peu d'intérêt
aujourd'hui pousser ces notions là ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que le
groupe de sécurité du président la
république
on doit lui donner la capacité de
s'entraîner le temps de travail d'un
agent de sécurité de la protection pour
moi lorsqu'il est bien organisée sur
décompose en trois temps un temps de
travail un temps d'entraînement et un
temps de repos
si c'est entre 3,6 et temps là ne sont
pas respectées la sécurité ne sera pas
bien assurée quand on n'est pas assez
nombreux qu'est-ce qu'il se passe on
empiète sur le temps d'entraînement
parfois on empiète même sur le temps de
repos ça doit rester exceptionnel ça
peut se produire mais ça doit rester
exceptionnel moi j'ai souhaité que ces
temps là soient respectés par ailleurs
le président de la république lorsque
j'ai eu à m'en occuper avait une famille
sans doute plus nombreuses que les
autres chefs d'état dont j'ai parlé plus
qu'un plus grand nombre d'enfants
ce qui s'imposait à moi nécessiter
davantage de fonctionnaires pour pouvoir
assurer cette mission
encore une fois ce chiffre
souvent les médias s'y intéressent de
très près lorsque le président la
république est élu
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi parce
que selon moi il est adapté aux besoins
moi si aujourd'hui le chef du j'espère à
le nombre d'agents de protection
suffisant en nombre c'est lui qui doit
en décider
moi j'ai x évaluer le fait que
cette mission pourrait être bien
accomplie elle devait être accompli par
de 90 à 100 fonctionnaires le chiffre a
pu varier
parce que l'émission ont pu varier
madame jourda merci monsieur prétend
monsieur le préfet nous avait indiqué
que la famille du président de la
république bénéficie également d'une
protection rapprochée de la part du
j'espère il peut arriver que cette
famille son conjoint par exemple se
déplace sans le président de la
république
dans ces conditions le j'espère
intervient aussi avez vous vu dans
l'exercice de vos fonctions que la
chefferie de cabinet suivait aussi le
conjoint du président de la république
dans les déplacements ou jeu conjoint et
sans le président bien sûr si le préfet
will épouse du président de la
république peut avoir des déplacements
qualifié d' officielle sans le président
de la république à titre caritatif dans
des fonctions elle souvent les épouses
des chefs d'état sont invités
donc elles répondent à cette invitation
et elles sont bien invité en tant
qu'épouse du président de la république
donc la chefferie de cabinet peut
déléguer quelqu'un pour gérer le
programme qui sera celui de l'épousé du
président de la république à ce moment
là mais on reste sur des moments que je
qualifie d' officiel même si on est un
peu à la frontière de l'officiel s'il a
pas de statut de l'épousé du président
la république en france mais ça s'impose
à nous
clairement si je fais un parallèle avec
ce que moi j'ai vécu aller à un concert
c'est pas un moment officiel mais on
peut être invité par une institution par
un hôpital par voilà dans des moments
plus caritatif et à ce moment là c'est
l'épousé du président qu'on invite et à
ce moment là bien sûr il peut y avoir un
membre de la chefferie cabinet parce que
tout simplement il y aura des relations
a organisé avec la préfecture
il y aura des relations avec les médias
organisée il y aura sans doute un
conseil a apporté l épouse du président
quant à léo déroulement de ce
déplacement
je vous remercie madame mercier merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
préfet pour vos propos pleins de sagesse
précis expérimenté votre sincérité et le
recul dont vous faites preuve
nous cherchons à cadrer le rôle exact de
monsieur les galas le général bio-farina
nous a expliqué qu'il était un interface
entre l'intérieur et l'extérieur moment
des événements ce qui a été confirmé par
monsieur benalla lui-même en particulier
en donnant une notion d'ambiance est-ce
que lors de vos travaux lorsque six
responsables de la sécurité vous aviez
quelqu'un une personne particulière qui
vous faisait part de l'ambiance qui
régnait lors des évènements et cela vous
semble-t-il important ce préfet il n'y
avait personne de désigner au sein de la
présence la république pour assurer ce
type d'information à mon profit les
capteurs qui mois pour moi été mis en
place mais tu est fourni par les
autorités locales par le préfet
territorialement compétent par le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique par le commandant de groupement
de la gendarmerie nationale par toute
autorité locale et à l'étranger de la
même façon voilà je n'ai pas besoin
d'interface le lien existe le lien je
voulais dit le l'agent de sécurité
rapprochée se se place comme un expert
conseiller auprès du préfet ou de
l'ambassadeur qui accueille le
déplacement et donc les échanges se
passe se situe à ce niveau là après les
autres éléments dont on pouvait avoir à
connaître c'est encore une fois
l'analyse de la menace
il ya des services de renseignement
compétent en france kiki qui vous
informe sur le niveau de dangerosité de
risque du déplacement ou ou de l'instant
pour lequel dans lequel vous êtes que
pour que vous avez en charge
je vois pas trop ce rôle interface je
n'imagine pas trop je vous remercie
monsieur waterblez merci monsieur le
président je préfère si vous aviez
constater qu'un collaborateur ou
quelqu'un qui est proche président lors
de ce dépassement porter une arme
auriez-vous alors c'est l'objectif
prévenu votre ministre de tutelle le miz
l'intérieur attaques personnelles
alors monsieur le préfet même si j'avais
constaté qu' une personne était porteuse
d'une heure alors que à mon sens il n'y
en avait pas le rôle je n'en aurai pas
rendu compte que j'aurai effectué un
contrôle je pense que j'aurai interpellé
la personne ou demander aux forces
locales de vérifier pourquoi cet
individu était porteur d'une arme
mais clairement parce que pour moi armes
égales forces de sécurité intérieure ça
s'arrête là donc si c'est un individu
que je ne connais pas je le fais
contrôler parce que potentiellement pour
moi il est une menace si cette année
individus que je connais je je vais m'en
étonner et je vais je pense qu'on aura
une explication
oui parce que la question de monsieur
wattebled plus quelqu'un qui est proche
du président ouais bah déplacement et en
tant que responsable ce que le président
quelqu'un qui a une ombre et on le sait
on le voit votre rôle et je suis natif
là c'est pas dans le cas actuel
auriez-vous prévenu l'autorité pour au
moins que ça se sache
bref vous vous seriez vous opposer à ce
qu'un collaborateur du président de la
république
la compagne en déplacement avec une arme
je m'en serais étonné je pense pas que
je me serais adressé au miso l'intérieur
je pense pas que ce soit du niveau de sa
responsabilité je vais m'en serais
ouvert au chef de cabinet directeur de
cabinet au secrétaire général de la
présidence de la république ça me semble
plus adapté
n'ayant jamais été confronté à cette
situation je peux pas vous en dire
davantage mais voilà c'est pas une
situation à laquelle j'ai été confronté
je vous remercie monsieur segouin merci
monsieur le président ma question était
en partie poser problème monsieur le
préfet non juste pour compléter monsieur
benalla nous a expliqué qu'il avait un
permis pour dames uniquement pour sa
sécurité et rien d'autre donc on peut
considérer qu'il représentait mais il
avait des menaces sur lui et en étendant
le premier cercle du président est de
créer de nouvelles menaces
enfin des menaces supplémentaires
était-il opportun à votre avis de la
voir dans ce premier cercle des préfets
j'ai indiqué que si pour moi un membre
du cabinet du président de la république
fait l'objet d'une menace la solution la
plus adaptée c'est de lui affecter une
sécurité rapprochée c'est pas de données
n'a encore une fois la sécurité est là
pour vous enlever les soucis liés à
cette menace et pour que vous puissiez
vous concentrer exclusivement à votre
travail
c'est ma conception de la sécurité c'est
vous enlever ses soucis voilà je ne sais
quoi quoi dire d'autre
et j'ai oublié la fin de votre question
donc enfin la fin de ma question c'était
de savoir si vous pouviez agir en tant
que j'espère pour connus qui ne soit pas
dans le premier cercle puisque
représentait une menace supplémentaire
pour le président et était-il
indispensable au point de le garder dans
ce premier cercle constitué une menace
supplémentaire non vous savez les
personnes à proximité du président de la
république également menacé il y en a
tout le temps il ya d'autres chefs
d'état étrangers d'autre des membres du
gouvernement français des personnalités
qui bénéficient d'une sécurité
ça ne constitue pas une menace
supplémentaire vrai président de la
république que d'être soi même menacé de
se trouver à proximité lui c'est après
un un critère un critère un paramètre
qu'on prend en compte et qui nécessite
une coordination souvent avec la
sécurité de la personne en question
parce que rarement j'ai été confronté à
jamais j'ai été confronté à quelqu'un
qui se sécurise est par lui-même
donc pensez vraiment que c'est pas dans
ce milieu là c'est s'est pas adapté au
milieu qui est qu'elle vient non voilà
on peut postuler que quand on est dans
le périmètre du groupe de sécurité du
président de la république et qu'on est
soi-même collaborateurs du président de
la république on est compris dans la
protection qui s applique au président
de la république
et à son environnement on peut on peut
postuler
on peut en bénéficier oui alors je vous
remercie
nous donnons toujours la parole aux
collègues non membre de la commission
des lois qui ont qui manifestent de
l'intérêt pour cette commission et je
les remercie de leur présence ce
monsieur pierre charon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet remontons le cours des siècles le
général de gaulle lorsqu'il se déplaçait
avec un peu un mini j'espère quatre
personnes dirigées par le commissaire
paul comiti et il était très efficace
lors de déplacement en bretagne
un jour une pomme est tombé sur le capot
de la déesse noire du général et le soir
le préfet a été déplacé vous est il
arrivé dans vos déplacements
pour le président de la république
française nicolas sarkozy d'avoir eu ce
genre de problème
je pense notamment à un déplacement dans
la manche où les préfets en charge de la
sécurité n'était pas tout à fait formé
pour faire cette sécurité et n'écoutez
pas les conseils de vos précurseur la
manche est un département
particulièrement sur mon cher collègue
et donc je sais pas si cet exemple mais
il ya beaucoup de pommes et peut-être
encore plus qu'en bretagne
alors monsieur le préfet je vois quel
déplacement vous faites référence
j'ai effectivement effectivement eu à
organiser un déplacement dans la manche
dont on peut dire qu'ils ne s'étaient
moyennement bien déroulé à savoir que le
président de la république avait eu à
traverser des groupes de manifestants
avec son cortège ce qui en aucune en
aucune façon on était une bonne manière
d'agir puisque on aurait dû éviter ces
six lieux les contourner ils n'ont pas
et ne pas espérer que aucun manifestant
ne se jettent sur le véhicule du
président la république vous le ne la
grèce ce qui ne s'était pas ce qui ne
s'est heureusement pas passer il est
vrai que
les conseils qu'on avait que j'avais pu
que les membres du j'espère l'époque
avait pu prodiguer n'ont pas été suivis
et encore une fois c'est ce que je dis
le j'espère le se porte comme un expert
auprès du préfet territorialement
compétent il est le seul responsable est
le seul compétent a décidé de toute
décision
je pense que c'est ce jour là ma mauvais
choix a été effectué je ne saurais dire
si l'avenir de ce préfet et eliès à ce
déplacement
mais en tout état de cause ce jour-là il
pour moi une erreur a été commise
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
préfet de notre expertise et d'avoir
répondu avec précision et de manière eux
très réfléchie évidemment à toutes les
questions qui vous ont été posées merci
voilà pour l'audition du préfet bénard
part à la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale sur la sphère benalla
audition vous avez pu suivre en direct
sur notre antenne
s'ils ont particulièrement intéressante
qui a mis de nouveau en lumière et bien
peut-être quelques contradictions
exprimé sur la fonction exacte
d'alexandre benalla au sein de la
présidence de la république vous le
savez c'est justement le coeur de cette
commission d' enquête sénatoriale est là
on va retrouver à tam train de nuit qui
a suivi
pour nous cette audition stamm vous êtes
devant le foyer et clemenceau vous avez
attiré trois enseignements des propos du
préfet
j'aime faire libre
alors ta maman nous entend pas très bien
on va revenir vers vous dans un instant
le temps de régler ce petit souci de son
jeu le disait l'ancien préfet à michel
ménard est revenu sur sa fonction c'est
lui qui dirigeait le groupement de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy il a permis un éclairage
supplémentaire aux sénateurs justement
sur le rôle et bien qu'il pouvait y
avoir et notamment le rôle des membres
de ce g sprl les auditions vont se
poursuivre ce matin puisque les
sénateurs continuent leurs travaux
parlementaires
il y aura un temps fort aussi à venir
avec les dirigeants du pin apps mais on
vous retrouve le thème travelling
puisque vous décrypter pour nous à cette
audition du préfet michel bénard
oui un plusieurs enseignements avec
cette addition du préfet michel bénard
tout d'abord est bien le fait
qu'alexandre benalla et eu un permis de
port d'armes à l'elysée alors même qu'il
ne faisait pas partie ni du g espère ni
du commandement militaire paraît inédit
puisque michel bénard a dit que lui
n'avait jamais eu connaissance de
personnalités ainsi qu'ils
n'appartenaient pas et bien à la
sécurité rapprochée du président de la
république qui est ce permis de port
d'armé il a été interrogé plusieurs fois
là dessus et à chaque fois il a répondu
la même chose s'il y avait eu des
risques personnels pour quelqu'un qui
est dans le premier cercle du chef de l'
du président de la république eh bien
cette personne on lui aurait attribué et
bien une protection rapprochée plutôt
que de lui donner une arme autre chose
et bien sûr la position d' alexandre b
n'est là que l'on peut voir dans les
déplacements toujours très proche du
président de la république est bien
michel bénard a dit qu'elle n'était pas
forcément caractéristiques de celle d'un
officier de sécurité que l'an tout cas
lorsque l'on voit alexandre benalla
malgré sa proximité avec le président de
la république on ne peut pas savoir si
les membres de cabinets osciller en
charge de la sécurité
michel bénard qui a d'ailleurs fait état
du fait qu'il pouvait y avoir je le cite
des parasites des courtisans dans le
premier cercle des personnalités
toujours très proche du président de la
république qui peuvent être une gêne
d'ailleurs pour les officiers de
sécurité du gspr un obstacle dont
parfois ils font un avantage ils peuvent
devenir des matelas de protection le
rôle du j'espère at il dit c'est
toujours de s'adapter
c'est le rôle de la protection à la
française faire en sorte d'avoir un lien
de confiance totale avec le président de
la république pour s'adapter at-elle
toutes les contraintes et à tous les
proches du président de la république
enfin un autre enseignement peut-être
est bien le fait que et bien michel
bénard a jugé que pour lui et bien il
n'y avait pas besoin de réformer et bien
les liens entre les j'espère et le
commandement militaire en tout cas
lorsque lui même était à la tête du
j'espère c'était très très clair il
avait la sécurité du président de la
république
à l'extérieur du palais présidentiel qui
était assurée par le j'espère composé de
membres de policiers membres soit du
service de protection des hautes
personnalités soient issus du raid
et puis d'autre part bien au sein du
palais présidentiel il y avait le
commandement militaire il a aussi
expliqué à travers et bien un historique
comment et bien ça avait pu se passer à
travers les différentes présidence de la
république on l'a vu le geste air
n'avait pas toujours les mêmes missions
sous nicolas sarkozy il avait aussi la
mission d'organisation des déplacements
ce qui sous emmanuel macro et choix
plutôt et bien à la chefferie de cabinet
et qui était la responsabilité
d'alexandre benalla en tout cas d'après
ce que l'on nous a dit à travers les
différentes auditions jusqu'ici merci à
vous au tam pour toutes ces précisions
suite de notre édition spéciale ce matin
toujours en direct sur public sénat à
l'occasion de nouvelles auditions de la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur
cette sénatoriale sur cette affaire
benalla sets aux tours et bien à présent
du préfet jean-paul la sellette d'être
entendu c'est l'ancien directeur du
conseil national des activités privées
de sécurité le cnaps on sait que
alexandre benalla avait été référencés
par cet organisme alors on va en savoir
peut-être un peu plus dans quel contexte
l'ancien chargé admission apparaît sur
ce fichier
en tous les cas là
l'émission enquête poursuit ses travaux
et notamment elle cherche à savoir et
bien comment était organisé la sécurité
rapprochée du président écoute si tu as
fini bas qui est préfet et ancien
directeur du conseil national des
activités privées de sécurité
le cnaps et vous avez exercé cette
fonction jusqu'au mois d'août si je
comprends bien
jusqu'au 27 août donc vous avez bien en
mémoire tous les paramètres de cette
mission et le cnaps du temps où vous le
dis rivier a eu à connaître un certain
nombre de demandes de qui lui ont été
présentés par monsieur benalla pour
l'exercice de fonctions d'agent de
sécurité mais aussi pour être agréé
comme comme dirigeant de l'entreprise de
sécurité
si vous le voulez bien je vais vous
proposer peut-être de prendre la parole
pour nous expliquer la nature de cet
organisme
les procédures qui ne suit les
vérifications qu'elle il procède avant
de délivrer les agréments ou
autorisation qui relève de sa compétence
puis nos rapporteur et nos collègues
vous posons certainement mais quelques
questions alors je vous laisse la parole
si vous souhaitez la prendre mais avant
avant j'allais au m l'essentiel c'est
que je dois vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant une autre commission
des lois doté des prérogatives d'une
commission denquête serait passible de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros damende je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je jeu et vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai donc comme vous l'avez dit monsieur
le président
l'honneur de diriger le cnaps de février
2016 au 27 août 2010 8
le cnaps et tu donc c'est le conseil
national des activités privées de
sécurité a trois missions principales
pour lanvin pour les principales
activités de sécurité privée qui sont la
surveillance et le gardiennage
surveillance par des moyens humains ou
par des moyens électroniques la
protection physique des personnes et le
transport de fonds les détectives privés
et de nouvelles activités comme la
protection armée des navires depuis deux
ans dans ce champ d'activité
le cnaps à trois missions principales il
délivre premièrement des titres il
délivre environ cent cinquante mille
titres par an dont notamment des cartes
professionnelles pour l'ensemble de ses
activités et des agrémentent dirigeants
il délivre également des autorisations
d'exercice à la fois pour les sociétés
de sécurité privées et pour les
organismes de formation
il délivre ses titres au regard de
critères un premier critère qui le
critère de moralité et pour cela le
cnaps al la possibilité l'habilitation
même pour consulter un certain nombre de
fichiers dont le casier judiciaire le b2
dont le tage et dont le fichier des
personnes recherchées
et deuxièmement il délivre un titre au
regard de la qualification
professionnelle soit vérifiée par là un
diplôme un certificat de qualification
professionnelle ou un titre ou un titre
universitaire soit pour certaines
catégories
je crois qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler pour certaines catégories
notamment pour les anciens agents des
forces de l'ordre et pour les gens et
pour les certains militaires par
équivalence le cnaps ne fa le directeur
du cnaps ne délivre pas lui même les
titres
il propose il propose donc l'acceptation
ou le refus d'une demande de titres à
une commission locale qui est composé de
fonctionnaires de magistrats et de
représentants des organisations
professionnelles etc
le président de cette commission qui
après délibération accepte ou non le la
demande de titres sur proposition bien
évidemment du directeur du club
si la décision ne convient pas ou n'est
pas accepté par le demandeur il peut
toujours faire appel devant la
commission nationale
la cnacg présidé par un avocat général
de la cour de cassation et dont le vice
président est un conseiller d'état voilà
pour ce qui est de la délivrance de
titres
la deuxième mission c'est une mission de
contrôle le qnap se réalise a réalisé en
2017 environ 1800 contrôle sur
l'ensemble des activités que j'ai cités
contrôle qui peuvent conduire à des à
des demandes disciplinaire les sanctions
qui sont proposés par le directeur est
prononcée par les commissions locales
peuvent aller jusqu'à une interruption
temporaire d'exercice de cinq ans et la
dernière mission qui vous intéressera
petit - est une mission de conseil
auprès des entreprises et des pouvoirs
publics
j'ajouterai simplement que nous
réalisions alors je dis encore nous même
si je ne suis plus le directeur mais
nous réalisons régulièrement des ce
qu'on appelle des rétros criblage et
nous revoyons une un titre est valable
pour cinq ans mais nous revoyons tous
les deux ans l'ensemble des titres en
cours de validité
il y en a 350 1321 mille pardons pour
être très précis actuellement valide et
s'il y a 6 est apparu au cours des deux
ans postérieure à délivrance du titre
une mention dans un des fichiers le
directeur demande enfin en tout cas
c'était ma pratique demande le retrait
des titres
voilà monsieur le président
grossièrement dit ce qu'elle aime ce que
sont les missions du cnaps alors j'y
ajouterai une chose si vous me le
permettez
le cnaps des livres des titres mais ne
n'interfère pas ou n'a aucune compétence
pour la délivrance de port d'armes
c'est le préfet qui est compétent le
préfet ou le ministre qui est compétent
en matière de port d'armes
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
mais c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait
logique puisque le port d'armes pour un
agent de sécurité privé jusqu'à des lois
récentes et est interdit et il est
toujours dans la mesure où les textes ne
sont plus les nouveaux textes ne sont
pas exactement mise en oeuvre vous avez
achevé
merci monsieur le préfet madame jourdain
monsieur sur madame jourdain
madame journal merci monsieur le
président pour préciser encore plus ce
que vous venez de nous indiquer sur la
façon dont vous travaillez et les
pouvoirs dont vous disposez je reste à
savoir combien de temps dure et
l'instruction des dossiers en moyenne et
de quels pouvoirs d'investigation vous
disposez vous nous avez indiqué pouvoir
consulter par exemple le but à gameiro 2
pouvez vous aussi auditionné les
intéressés et éventuellement ses préfets
monsieur président donc nous délivrons
s'il n'y a aucune difficulté aucune
mention dans les fichiers consultés et
si il est clairement établi
si la qualification professionnelle est
clairement établi à travers un titre
nous pouvons délivrer un titre en moins
de cinq jours
si en revanche il apparaît des mentions
alors nous sommes obligés d'engager une
enquête administrative enquête
administrative qui peut durer jusqu'à
deux mois parfois plus d'ailleurs
puisque nous devons à la fois engagé une
enquête administrative
mais nous devons aussi consulter les
parquets s'il y a une mention taz ou une
mention au b2 et bien évidemment parfois
beaucoup plus si il y à une mention au
fpr et notamment avec une mention de sur
la sûreté nationale puisque là nous
consultons les services spécialisés
merci madame jourdain demander si
l'audition des intéressés pouvaient
intervenir
le dot manière il ya toujours un
contradictoires donc le contradictoire
se fait soit par écrit
il peut y avoir une audition c'est pas
une ne suis pas nécessairement une
audition mais ça peut se faire
tom jourdain alors entre ont peut-être
sur le cap plus précis de monsieur
benalla qui avait sollicité différents
titres auprès du cnaps concernant sa
carte professionnelle d'agent de
sécurité privée je reste à voir j'aurais
souhaité avoir quelques éléments précis
sur la date de la délivrance pour la
première fois la date de renouvellement
quels étaient les compétences et
justificatifs qui était joint à sa
demande
et quelle activité cette carte
autorise-t-elle concrètement alors
pour ce qui le concerne le cas de
monsieur benalla il à jérémy de dire que
le cnaps a été créé en 2012
préalablement c'était les préfectures
qui délivrer les autorisations monsieur
benalla obtenu une carte en 2011 qui a
été délivrée par la préfecture de l'eure
et qui l'autorisait à exercer une
activité de protection physique des
personnes il a demandé une extension de
sa carte en 2014 le 20 janvier 2014 et
il a demandé une extension sur
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée la surveillance humaine et le
gardiennage le transport de fonds la
sûreté aéroportuaire et opérateurs de
vidéoprotection et il l'a fait au regard
de deux critères premièrement aucune
moralité n'a été n'a été vérifiée donc
il y avait les fichiers étaient vierges
et deuxièmement pour sa compétence ou sa
qualification professionnelle il a fait
jouer
l'équivalence puisqu'il a été
réservistes opérationnels et dès lors
une carte lui a été délivré au regard de
ces deux critères
il a fait une dernière demande très
récemment le 28 juin 2010 7,18
non non pas pour obtenir cette fois ci
une carte professionnelle lui permettant
d'exercer une activité de sécurité
privée mais pour obtenir un agrément de
dirigeants les deux critères qui lui ont
permis d'obtenir cet agrément dirigeants
c'est d'une part une fois encore une
moralité et zfs à une moralité normal si
je fais des formalités une moralité et
deuxièmement deux diplômes parce que
nous vérifions pour les agréments
dirigeants la capacité de la personne à
exercer une activité de dirigeants et
donc il a fourni deux diplômes une
licence qui était une licence de de
droit économie gestion mention
administrations publiques et il arrivera
et il a délivré également un une un
titre de master 1 en sécurité publique
qui était délivré par l'université
d'auvergne clermont ferrand
c'est pourquoi la carte les cartes
professionnelles à la fois une carte
professionnelle et un agrément de
dirigeants lui ont été délivrés il a
donc deux titres j'ajouterai
qu'aujourd'hui enfin que avant que soit
mis fin à mes fonctions j'ai demandé le
retrait de ces deux titres au regard de
l'apparition de nouvelles mentions sur
les fichiers je vous remercie monsieur
le préfet madame jourdain ouï à aucun
moment été indiqué dans ce dossier la
qualité de monsieur bédard qui
travaillait à l'elysée comme agent
public et si cela avait été indiqué cela
était-il incompatible avec sa demande
alors nous délivrons une carte
professionnelle au regard donc des
critères que je vous ai indiqué sans
considérer si la personne est oui ou non
engagé dans une société de sécurité
privée ou ailleurs donc à aucun moment
nous n'avions connaissance où nous
n'avions nécessairement connaissance de
son appartenance à telle ou telle
administration et nous délivrons des
cartes donc sans même demander à qui
va a calé l'employeur de la personne qui
meuble merci monsieur le préfet vous
n'avez rien à ajouter sur ce point à
nadjaf vous avez d'autres questions
le monsieur le président sur monsieur le
préfet je vous aviez été professeur de
philosophie et je vous ai demandé tout à
l'heure quelle était votre philosophe
préféré ça m'intéresse et vous avez dit
ou sol et nous aussi mais ce qui
intéresse le reconnais vous savez bien
que husserl à développer madame benbassa
le sait et d'autres collègues aussi une
importante philosophie de
l'intentionnalité et est ce que vous
vous êtes posé la question s'agissant de
monsieur ben alla des raisons pour
lesquelles l'intention finalement pour
laquelle il demandait ses différents
titres ces différents agréments fc part
nous sommes sénateurs ici nous n'avons
pas forcément l'idée de demander un
agrément pour être dirigé une société de
sécurité privée voyez vous et quand on
est son cabinet adjoint au chef de
cabinet à la présidence de la république
franchement
on veut se demander pourquoi finalement
il y à cette demande
mais cette question ne vous a pas
effleuré
et quand vous avez dit tout à l'heure
j'ajoute deuxième élément gens voir une
autre question après mais quand vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous n'aviez
pas vous intéresser à l'employeur de la
personne ou à son travail quand même
vous êtes un préfet de la république
vous connaissez bien les choses le
ministère de l'intérieur la présidence
il ne pouvait vous échapper me
semble-t-il que monsieur benalla était
aussi adjoint au chef de cabinet du
président de la république
voilà ces deux questions monsieur préfet
quant à l'intentionnalité de la demande
les textes ne sont claires jeu dès lors
que la personne remplit si je puis dire
les deux conditions à la fois de
moralité et de qualification
professionnelle le match sauf réserves
de la part de la commission locale
d'agrément et de contrôle
le cnaps doit délivrer le titre est
jeune et je ne fais le cnaps n'a pas à
aller chercher d'autres motifs les
motivations de la demande soit la
personne remplit les conditions soient
ne les envie pas ce qui aurait pu
être ensuite regarder c'est lors d'un
contrôle là le titre d'agrément
l'agrément dirigeante
il date du 28 juin 2018
donc nous n'avons pas sûrs que nous
n'avions pas eu encore la possibilité de
nous intéresser à monsieur bnl surtout
que l'agrément il a il est il a obtenu
un argué vraiment comme tous ceux qui
obtiennent un agrément sans même
préciser si oui ou non ils allaient
créer une société et le cnaps ne pouvait
pas sauf contrôle savoir quelle société
ils allaient créer voire même s'il avait
créé une société
donc c'est au moment du contrôle que
nous aurions pu et d'autre part monsieur
benalla je les avais rencontrés une fois
très récemment aux archives aux dents
lors d'une manifestation sur les assises
de la sécurité privée
mais je ne fais moi je ne savais pas que
monsieur benalla avait fait ces demandes
particulières
ça ne m'était pas nécessairement
remonter puisque aucune apps donc il y a
un siège et il y à des directions
territoriales et monsieur benalla
faisait ses demandes auprès de la
direction de l'île de france
mais une fois encore c'est au moment du
contrôle que la question aurait pu être
tout pertinente au moment du dépôt des
demandes nous traitons quand même 150
mille demandes
il n'y avait pas de deux
signal particulier quant à ses demandes
ils remplissaient les conditions et nous
les avons vérifié je voulais vous
demander comment vous jugez de la
moralité une demande ou d'un personnage
mais dont vous avez un détective privé
comment vous faites pour savoir il est
moral alors nous avons la moralité selon
le texte
elle se vérifie au regard des fichiers
consultés eu d'accord sécu rebond
mécanique tout sauf s'il y a une mention
particulière alors nous engageons une
enquête administrative
mais si les fichiers sont vierges
nous n'avons aucun motif d'aller au delà
de ta consultation des fichiers non
seulement aucun motif mais nous n'en
avons pas la compétence très bien alors
la deuxième et dernière question si vous
permettez monsieur le président concerne
monsieur vincent kraz alors elle
comporte deux sous questions concernant
les deux demandes de carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privées qui ont également été demandé
par vincent bhl sur un centre ases nous
avons auditionné
quand ces cartes lui ont-elles été
délivré au vu de quelle compétence et de
quelle justificatifs quelles activités
autorisées tel concrètement et
concernant c'est le deuxième volet de la
question
sa récente demande d'agrément en qualité
de dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
privée et d'autorisation d'exercer cette
fonction de dirigeant d'une telle
entreprise
quand cette demande at elle été
présentés et quelle suite lui ont-elles
été réservé comme suit président sur la
votre première question concernant les
demandes
monsieur crade a fait une demande de
carte professionnelle en 2013
c'est ça et elle concernait les
activités de détectives privés
sur quels motifs sur quel bouton ok qui
sont quel titre
d'une part parce qu'ils pouvaient
justifier dans sa qualité de réserviste
opérationnel de la gendarmerie nationale
d'une équivalence
mais il disposait également d'un diplôme
d'université d'enquêteurs privés livré
par l'université paris 2 et donc qu'il
lui a été délivré dans un premier temps
en 2013 une carte de détectives privés
il a demandé en 2014 l'extension de
cette carte à d'autres activités
en fait à toutes les autres activités de
sécurité privée et il l'a fait sur deux
va en remplissant de critères d'une part
une fois encore la moralité vérifier
comme enfin la moralité au regard des
textes du livre 6 du code de la sécurité
intérieure et deuxièmement au regard par
équivalence au regard de son passé de
façon de son passé de son expérience de
réservistes opérationnels de la
gendarmerie nationale donc qu'il a une
carte professionnelle il dispose d'une
carte professionnelle qui couvre
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée tel que le définit le livre 6 du
code de la sécurité intérieure en
revanche quand à sa demande d'agrément
qu'il a fait aux le 4 avril 2018 sa
demande d'agrément deux dirigeants a été
implicitement rejeté dans la mesure où
on le
le dossier était incomplet et pourquoi
le dossier était incomplet parce qu'il
ne pouvait justifier d'une qualification
professionnelle lui permettant de
diriger une société
merci au journal vous vouliez poser une
autre question
oui merci monsieur le président vous
avez indiquée à deux reprises que
l'équivalence avait été accordée à temps
monsieur aka monsieur kraz en raison de
leur qualité de réserviste dans la
réserve opérationnelle
je présume que le critère il plus précis
il faut avoir été appelé un certain
nombre de jours qu'elle est écrite
quel est le critère plus précisément
décliner ses préfets ses pendants
près de 20 pendant trois ans mais ce
qu'ils ont cependant oui ce qu'ils ont
pu justifier
en fait c'est l'article le ce qui
justifie l'obtention pour quelqu'un qui
a une expérience dans leur accueil a été
réservé east de la gendarmerie nationale
c'est les articles r 12 36 7 et r dos 43
du code de la sécurité intérieure s'il
faut je sais pas si je vous en fais
lecture où l'on voit merci je préfère
que vous avez indiqué qu'avant d'avoir
quitter vos fonctions vous aviez
enclencher la procédure de retrait de la
carte d'agent de sécurité et de
l'agrément de dirigeants quand on
enclenche une telle procédure je suppose
que papa glisse mme des formes mais une
commission locale qui se réunit puis sur
avis de cette commission locale le
président du cnaps prend la décision
cette procédure prend combien de temps
là normalement la procédure peut être
peut-être relativement simple ceci dit
dans ce cas précis il faudra
nécessairement que s'engage une nouvelle
enquête administrative
donc elle peut cette enquête
administrative au regard de la situation
des deux intéressés peut prendre du
temps
néanmoins les demandes ont été faites et
donc sont aujourd'hui en cours
d'instruction auprès des commissions
locales
l'agrément est contre mais aucune des
deux personnes concernées n'a fait
l'objet de la moindre condamnation à ce
que néanmoins on considère dans la
jurisprudence encore récente du cnaps
que les poursuites dont ils font l'objet
suffisent à la retirer la carte et
l'agrément nous fin ne j'ai considéré
que et ça tu sais pas simplement pour le
k2
ces deux personnes c'est le cas général
j'ai considéré que dès lors que des
faits était publiquement à tester la
moralité peut être regardée par tous
moyens
enfin dès lors que j'ai considéré que
dès lors que des faits était attestée et
que des ces faits étaient déjà introduit
dans les fichiers notamment dans le
tages il mais il m'était possible de
demander le retrait des cartes dans la
mesure où je considérais tels que les
textes d'ailleurs sont rédigées je
considérais que les actes étaient
incompatibles avec l'exercice d'une
activité de sécurité privée je peux vous
en donner d'autres exemples a vu un
agent de sécurité privée qui commet des
actes de violence à l'égard d'une
personne sans doute sdf dans une gare
que cette ces actes sont filmés et
apparaissent sur les réseaux sociaux
puis ensuite dans la presse mon permis
de demander et d'obtenir le retrait de
la carte de l'individu en question
on vous avait appliqué une doctrine de
l'organisme qui avait eu à jouer dans
d'autres cas pas pour les mêmes actes
mais pour des actes sont anciennement
délictueux mais avérés et je vous
remercie pas d'autres questions de nos
deux rapporteurs madame lherbier
monsieur préfet la première carte qui
avait été attribué à monsieur ménard
vous avez dit était de 2011 il avait 19
ans et 20 ans
y avait peu d'expérience encore pour
cette première carte je dois vous me
donniez quelques précisions et j'aurais
voulu aussi savoir quand la personne
obtient le port d'armes
la deuxième carte lui permet peut-être
d'avoir des missions plus élargie
d'avoir un agrément plus conséquent
est-ce que c'est noté 7
ce changement de situation avant et
après le port d'armes
c'est le préfet la matrice sur votre
première question 2011 c'est la
préfecture qui délivre et je ne connais
pas la doctrine de la préfecture de
l'eure aller à l'époque oui en 2011
puisque le club ce n'est n'est créée
qu'en 2012
ceci dit l'équivalence doit être à ce
moment là reconnu qu'elle que soit quel
que soit l'âge de la personne en
question
il est majeur et il a une expérience
dans le domaine de la réserve
opérationnelle ce qui au regard des
textes lui permettent d'obtenir un titre
par équivalence sur votre deuxième
question il est bien clair que dans la
jurisprudence comme dans les textes il
n'y a aucun lien on peut le regretter
d'ailleurs mais il n'y a aucun lien
entre l'obtention d'une carte par
exemple d'agents de sécurité pour la
protection physique des personnes et
l'obtention d'une porda d'un port
d'armes
et pour cause et pour cause parce que la
loi jusqu alors interdit explicitement
que l'activité de protection physique
des personnes soit exercée avec une âme
ce n'est que très récemment en 2017 que
la loi va modifier ce
cette disposition mais 2017 la loi la
modifie il a fallu attendre un décret et
les arrêtés d'application de ce décret
viennent à peine d'être de paraître ce
qui fait que pour l'instant il n'y a
même pas un organisme qui peut certifier
un organisme de formation pour
l'activité de protection physique des
personnes armées
ce qui fait que il pourra peut-être y
avoir des cartes professionnelles
délivrées dans ce domaine au mois de
juin de l'année prochaine
je vous remercie madame city folk ou
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet en réalité ma question a déjà été
posée donc simplement gelard formules
comme ça la demande donc de monsieur
benalla est intervenue le 20
juin 2018 donc postérieure aux faits du
1er mai mais antérieure à la divulgation
de la vidéo
donc ma question c'était simplement si
la demande était intervenue après le 19
juillet aurait-il eu son agrément mais
vous avez répondu je pense donc je ne
vais pas aller plus loin je vous
remercie
merci madame di folco ce préfet
simplement effectivement il y aurait
fallu mais je pense que la vigilance de
tous aurait été bien engagée il aurait
fallu que je sois alertés mais j'aurais
demandé le refus d'une telle demande
je remercie madame mercier si monsieur
le président monsieur le préfet nous
avait déclaré qu il a été mis fin à vos
fonctions en 2018 pouvez vous nous
préciser s'il vous plaît 7,7 fin
d'action 2d comme tout préfet j'ai été
nommé en donc par un décret fapa come to
prefects gt2 préfète territoriale
auparavant j'étais préfet de la haute
marne
j'ai été nommé par un décret du
président de la république je suis allée
disposition du gouvernement
le gouvernement a mis fin à mes
fonctions je n'ai pas de commentaire
d'autres commentaires ce n'était pas
votre pardon monsieur le président ce
n'est pas votre demande
ah non mais j'ai rarement été nommé à ma
demande saas et ça vous manifestez la
très grand sens du service public bien
nous allons à pardon madame de la
gontrie
excusez moi mais quelque chose qui me
qui m'intrigue
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la votre
demande de retrait des deux titres en
raison de nouvelles mentions sur les
fichiers est comme ça m'intriguait vous
avez immédiatement répondu par exemple
le tage alors cette demande et du 28
juin
mais ce que je ne comprends pas assez
alors je comprends que vous avez
l'agrément pour accéder otages mais je
ne comprends pas quel titre monsieur
benalla peut figurer otage pour le coup
enfin je ne suis pas sûr vous puissiez
message normalement ces antécédents
judiciaires hors que je sache ce n'est
pas le cas à ce jour ce qu'on peut noter
cependant c'est que et on ne peut que
veux saluer le votre réactivité
puisqu'il semble que vous ayez donc
estimé qu'il y avait lieu de retirer ses
titres alors que dans la même période
ils n'étaient pas
considérés comme pertinents d'engager
des poursuites
néanmoins il se trouve que deux mois
plus tard il était mis fin à vos
fonctions
donc voilà donc comment comprenez vous
que cette personne figure otage je sais
si tenté que vous ayez une explication
le tage et est un instrument parfois
lent parfois rapides dès lors que vous
êtes engagés
ce qui d'ailleurs curieux que soit comme
auteur soit comme victime soit comme
témoin parfois vous pouvez faire l'objet
d'une mention otage ses deux lancers
scellant cette heure oui on ne sait pas
c'est pas la pratique donc dès lors que
vous êtes engagés dans une procédure
j'ajouterai que j'ai j'ai demandé ces
retraits lors le cas que j'ai évoquées
qui était un cas parallèle j'ai demandé
les retraits en urgence parce que je
pense parce que la personne exerçant une
activité de sécurité privée dans les
deux cas qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
j'ai demandé simplement le retrait dans
une procédure normale
alors je peux pas je peux vous pourrez
vous donner les références précises mais
j'ai pas là merci monsieur le préfet est
en effet le seul fichier le taz est un
fichier très large et donc il suffit
qu'une personne fasse l'objet d'une
enquête judiciaire pour y être inscrits
même temporairement bien monsieur le
préfet merci de du concours que vous
avez apporté à notre mission
d'information cette audition est donc
terminée je ne vois pas de nouvelles
questions
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup
voilà pour l'audition du préfet
jean-paul celle est qui est revenu
longuement sur et bien les cartes
professionnelles dont avait bénéficié
alexandre benalla en matière de sécurité
rapprochée
jean paul siècle qui va laisser sa place
à un autre ancien directeur du cnaps
le criminologue alain bauer nous avons
cela vient benjamin morel nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
professeur de droit constitutionnel
on a vu là encore des auditions
particulièrement technique mais qui
éclaire de nouveau et bien les fonctions
d'alexandre bénin en tous les cas sa
mission de supposées auprès du chef de
l'état oui c'est qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses mais ça éclaire plus
tôt sur ce que voulaient faire ce cas ce
que ce que projetaient de faire
alexandre benalla en tant que chef d'une
société privée
ce que montre bien ces auditions c'est
qu'en fait il faut décorrélée cette
question de la question du port d'armes
comme l'a très bien dit le préfet et
bien ce qui dit le l'autorisation du
cnaps au port d'armes
soit on fait des lois très récente et
des décrets qui sont baru enfin des
arrêtés qui sont parus ya quelques jours
donc d'une certaine façon là dessus et
bien alexandre benalla ne peut pas se
prévaloir de son autorisation du cnaps
pour et bien plaidé le fait qu'il
portait une âme la morale on va
retrouver à terme tran huy qui suit
également pour nous ces auditions tama
qu'avez vous retenu quels enseignements
avez vous tiré de cette seconde audition
ce matin bien oui il ya effectivement
pour rebondir sur ce que disait monsieur
morel et bien dès le début de son
audition et bien jean paul sartre a bien
dit que le cnap n'interfère pas avec la
délivrance du port d'armes qui vient
d'elle des préfets ou des ministres
alors de lors de cette audition vous
l'avez du on a eu plus tôt un historique
des conditions dans lesquelles est bien
alexandre benalla avait obtenu un
certain nombre d'habilitation de la
paraît bien du cnaps d'abord en ayant sa
carte d'agent de sécurité privée en 2011
pour la protection physique des
personnes qu'il a obtenu là à l'époque
de la préfecture de l'eure puisque le
cnaps n'a été créé qu'en 2000
12 on appris qu'en 2014 et bien il y
avait une extension de cette carte sur
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée
c'est plus large sûreté aéroportuaire
transferts de fonds ou encore vidéo
protection
et tout cela parce que il y avait bien
deux raisons 1 qu'il a été réservistes
opérationnels et ensuite parce que il
n'y a pas de problème moral qui a été
détecté et puis enfin on a appris et
bien que beaucoup plus récemment le 28
juin 2018 il ya une troisième demande
pour obtenir un agrément de dirigeants
qui l'a obtenu mais qui depuis lyon
était retiré 1 et la carte et cet
agrément deux dirigeants en raison des
derniers événements merci à vous tam
dans un amour elle professeur en
sciences politiques
or on sait que récemment à la cour des
comptes a émis un avis très sévère sur
le cnaps sa gestion est aussi le fait
qu'elle délivre assez facilement
finalement un des demandes de carte
professionnelle oui en effet le rapport
de la cour des comptes dit ya quelques
mois était quand même un peu au vitriol
par rapport aux cnaps même si bien sûr
la cour des comptes est un organe
civilisé qui prend des gants mais l'idée
en fait était que le cnaps étaient
gérées en grande partie par les
représentants de la profession et que
donc c'était certains établissements
publics même établissement public
d'abord et avant tout diriger un moral
en tous les cas pardon puisqu'un autre
ancien directeur du avec nate est
auditionné à ce matin il s'agit dans la
mort on l'écouté et on reviendra
ensemble est bien là sur cet objet sur
l' usage et de demander à chacune des
personnalités auditionnées de prêter
serment
je rappelle et je les fais à chaque fois
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois a doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure
jure je vous remercie si vous le
souhaitez vous pourriez introduire notre
échange par un propos liminaire je vous
donne la parole
éclairé mais alors de loin la commission
puisque que contrairement à l'idée qui
est répandu ni le président ni le
directeur du cnaps dans le pouvoir ni de
délivrer ni de retirer les cas la
construction qui a été fait pour le
cnaps avec l'inspecteur général
d'administration chez berlioz a été
justement de faire en sorte que l'outil
soit le plus décentralisée possible et
le moins soumis possible à toute
tentation ou toute tentative de délivrer
ou de retirer des cartes pour des
raisons qui ne sont pas expressément
prévues par le législateur où le pouvoir
exécutif lorsqu'il exerce sa mission
réglementaire et donc ce sont des
présidents de commissions locales qui
sont soit des magistrats soient des
préfets qui exerce cette mission et la
commission d'appel la commission
nationale d'agrément et de contrôle
et comme ceci a été indiqué précédemment
sous l'autorité conjointe d'un membre du
conseil d'état et d'un magistrat de la
cour de cassation
alternativement l'un ou l'autre mais
personne d'autre et le pouvoir exercé
par le président du clap ce nous avons
fait en sorte qu'il ne puisse pas être
membre de la commission d'agrément et de
contrôle dans une stricte séparation des
pouvoirs telle qu'elle a été d'ailleurs
imposé au fil des ans pour toutes les
autorités ayant un pouvoir disciplinaire
car le cnap s'exerce à la fois une
mission de police administrative une
fonction d'ordre professionnel et des
missions de sanctions non seulement
disciplinaire mais financières dans des
conditions qui ont été prévus dans
certains cas par législateur dans
d'autres cas plus ou moins bricoler et
dans certains cas avec des difficultés
d'exercice c'est le cas par exemple pour
la mission de retrait en urgence des
cartes mission qui n'existent pas alors
que le collège du cnap cela réclame de
manière régulière bien avant le cas qui
vous a
intéressé aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
nous pouvions par exemple délivrer des
sanctions financières mais nous ne
pouvions pas les percevoir ni vérifier
qu'elles l'étaient nous pouvions délivré
d interdiction d'exercice ou des
suspensions pour les entreprises mais
sans pouvoir les faire appliquer et pour
un très grand nombre d' enquête qui
dépasse la simple consultation des
fichiers et encore pas tous nous devons
relever d'une mission qui se rajoute à
celle innombrables qui sont confiées aux
policiers et aux gendarmes ou aux
autorités des services de renseignement
dans le cas de processus de
radicalisation qui peuvent interférer
donc nous avons à la fois beaucoup de
missions des pouvoirs alternatif et
beaucoup de contraintes dans l'exercice
en tout cas dans le contrôle de
l'exercice réel de ses pouvoirs et donc
nous sommes dans cette configuration qui
vous a été je crois expliqué par
directeur
le dernier directeur en titre mais même
pas l'actuel je ne crois pas en tout cas
mais qui pourrait évoluer eux-mêmes vous
expliquer depuis la création du club ce
qu'est la difficulté de l'exercice de
cette institution un peu baroque un peu
hybride qui a moins de pouvoir que
l'ordre des médecins mais qui a plus de
compétences qui a quelques limites à son
exercice donc le législateur comme le
gouvernement ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour rattraper le retard et nous mettre
en situation d'être plus efficaces ou
plus compétents la cour des comptes lors
d'un rapport récent a indiqué à la fois
tout ce qui était les déficiences du
cnaps
mais en indiquant qu' elle ne répondait
pas la problématique du cnaps lui-même
et des pouvoirs qui lui sont confiés ou
des moyens qui lui sont attribués et
donc c'est un assez long travail puisque
l'ensemble du processus législatif
évidemment prendre du temps même s'il
s'agit de corriger un oubli d'une demi
phrase dans un coin ou un titre dans un
autre nous n'avions pas par exemple pas
de code de déontologie obligatoire c'est
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et le collège du cnaps
eux mêmes qui ont souhaité se l'appliqué
à lui-même
nous avons à la fois des catégories très
complexe de population puisque chez les
détectives privés nous avons la foi des
salariés de cabinet de détectives et des
professions libérales qui ne se traite
évidemment pas de la même manière et qui
nous font bien d'ailleurs savoir quand
nous sommes dans des processus par
exemple de contrôle de la réalité de la
concurrence et notamment la concurrence
étrangères sur le territoire national du
fait de la virtualisation les frontières
se sont beaucoup estompée et puis nous
avons ce que l'état nous impose
notamment ce qui est les agréments et
les habilitations par équivalence ou
encore récemment il ya quelques semaines
un nouveau texte impose d'accueillir et
d'intégrer des personnels issus du monde
militaire dans des conditions
extrêmement allégées
ce qui n'est pas toujours la position du
collège du cnaps qui en général est plus
sévère ou plus strictes ou considérés
comme tels que l'idée que l'état se fait
de notre mission pour beaucoup de sujets
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous
indiquer comme arrière fond général sur
à la fois l'ampleur des missions et des
limites de l'exercice de ses missions
eu égard à la complexité de la volonté à
la fois du législateur dans certains cas
et du gouvernement dans l'autre merci de
ce propos liminaire monsieur jean pierre
sueur
monsieur le professeur vous avez vous
posé plusieurs questions de la première
est factuel et nonobstant ce que vous
venez de nous expliquer est ce que eux
les conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
donc été directeur du cnaps exercer des
missions au sein de cet organisme
les conditions dans lesquelles une carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privée et un agrément qualité de
dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
privée ont été attribué à monsieur
alexandre benalla vous paraissent tout à
fait régulière
même chose pour les demandes de carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privée et d'agrément en qualité
dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
privée et de l'autorisation d'exercer de
la direction d'une entreprise peut
attribuer à monsieur vincent kraz alors
du point de vue de la réglementation de
la végétation et des textes qui ont été
produits par le législateur et
l'autorité réglementaire
les autorisation initiale de monsieur
benallal ont été faites par le préfet
représentant direct de l'état il n'y
avait pas d'institutions collégiale pour
le délivrer son renouvellement de carte
est fait dans la plus parfaite
régularité sa demande d'habilitation et
d'agrément s'est fait après la fin de
mon mandat mais pour ce que j'en sais
aurais-je été président du clap cette
époque rien ne se serait opposé à sa
délivrance
la délivrance de la carte de monsieur
crasse effet parfaitement dans les mêmes
règles et dans le même respect strict
des textes et son refus d'agrément
dirigeant s'est fait dans le strict
respect des textes et l'absence de
constitution d'un dossier
complet oui le fait que monsieur benalla
soit adjoint au chef de cabinet du
président de la république il ne devait
pas en 2014
oui mais après après eux n'a pas posé de
questions relatif à une demande
d'agrément pour elisa ses nerfs que le
statut des non fonctionnaires
contractuels de droit public et
s'opposent 7
la possibilité à la fois parce qu'un
agrément il y à 325 peut-être un peu
moins 1000 cartes professionnelles dont
seulement 150 me d'actifs les autres ne
le sont pas c'est l'activité qui pose
problème la carte vous donne juste une
autorisation d'exercer
mais ne garantit pas l'exercice de cette
possibilité
c'est la même chose pour les agréments
des régions c'est une autorisation de
devenir des gens ce n'est pas le fait
que vous soyez dirigeants et
malheureusement la réglementation ne
prévoit rien d'autre que ce qui est déjà
le cas actuellement je vous ai donné je
vous ai imprimés ici une demande de
carte professionnelle
au cas où ça va très mal à si vous
noterez qu'à la fin de cette demande de
carte professionnelle
le collège a mis en place une
attestation qui interdit et qui rappelle
l'interdiction de cumul d'emplois avec
les fonctions publiques qui prévoit code
de la défense droits et obligations des
fonctionnaires au cumul d'activités des
fonctionnaires et qui demandent
expressément que et qui rappelle à celui
qui nous pose la question qu'ils
exercent ou pas d'activité qui lui est
interdit de l'exercer dans les cadres ou
la loi lui interdit expressément de le
faire nous sommes par a par contre face
à une difficulté je leur mets très
formellement l'inventeur du président
nous sommes par exemple par contre face
à une difficulté un militaire un
fonctionnaire de police un fonctionnaire
public qui prévoit sa retraite dans six
mois ou dans un an peut parfaitement à
ce titre demandé une demande de carte et
d'habilitation et l'exercé qu'au moment
où il n'est plus dans l'interdiction de
cumul
il peut par ailleurs parfaitement
demandé à exercer le cumul notamment
s'il est employée à mi-temps ou dans
toute une série de dérogations qui
existe dans le code général de la
fonction publique qui sait de ce point
de vue là beaucoup élargie et a surpris
au fil des ans et donc il faut le
traiter au cas par cas
par ailleurs comme ceci vous avez été
indiqué je crois précédemment nous
contrôlons normalement l'écart tous les
cinq ans c'est ce que faisaient les
préfectures depuis les problématiques
général indique notamment de lutte
antiterroriste des processus dit de
lutte contre la radicalisation
nous avons fait un contrôle général
avant l'euro 2016 pour des raisons qui
paraissait légitime à tous
nous faisons désormais un contrôle
général de l'ensemble des cartes tous
les deux ans je dis bien l'ensemble des
cars 300 et quelques milles plus ce qui
scelle que nous délivrons tous les ans
environ 100000 puisque le rythme de
renouvellement s'accélère et que le taux
de rotation de la profession de la
sécurité privée notamment largué neige
est supérieure à 70 % dont 70% dès
agents change soit d'emploi soit
d'employeurs tous les ans ce qui amène
un taux de rotation considérables et
donc une activité permanente du cnaps en
plus de du pic qui arrivent tous les
cinq ans des reprises d'activités des
reprises d'activité à temps partiel des
compléments d'activité en cas de besoin
majeur
imaginons les jeux olympiques par
exemple c'est un sujet totalement majeur
où le niveau de préparation reste
aujourd'hui encore très faible par
rapport aux besoins qui va s'exercer et
où probablement l'ensemble de la
population titulaires d'une carte va
revenir à ce moment précis si le cnaps
suit les instructions qui ont été
données au moment de l'euro 2016 et bien
toutes les cartes toutes les cartes vont
devoir être revisitée avant
l'ouverture du processus préalable aux
jeux olympiques et toute la durée des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques donc
ceci explique l'ampleur du dispositif
nécessaire pour fonctionner mais là
l'existence tant qu'elle n'est pas
publiée au journal officiel dans ce cas
précis et d'ailleurs nous ne sommes
peut-être pas au courant de l'activité
exact de monsieur benalla allait viser
je ne suis pas sûr que grand monde
savait très exactement ce qu'il y
faisait avant que la presse et les
commission denquête décide de révéler ce
qui était la réalité de ces contrats à
ma connaissance le fait qu'il ne
l'indiquent pas est la situation exacte
devait être regardée au vu de exactement
ce qu'ils faisaient des horaires qu'il
faisait mais il interdit absolu en
termes de code général de la fonction
publique
à ma connaissance ne s'appliquait pas à
son cas par ailleurs ne se serait pas
appliquée à sont capables merci
attention deuxième question
l'autorisation du président la demande
est là pour moi oui elle est accordée va
porter sur une question plus générale
et là je voulais vous interrogez en tant
que spécialiste reconnu des questions de
sécurité
il y a deux entités à l'elysée chargé de
la sécurité de la protection du
président de la république
le gspr et le commandement militaire
les personnels exerçant les missions
dans ces deux organismes où ces deux
entités relève du ministère de
l'intérieur ou du ministère de la
défense en cotutelle pour ceux qui sont
militaires
il a été dit par monsieur benalla dans
le journal du dimanche que par rapport à
ce qui pouvait être un projet par
rapport auquel nous ne savons pas très
exactement le rôle qu'il jouait puisque
nous avons plusieurs versions il y avait
une opposition du ministère de
l'intérieur
eux et ils quelle est votre appréciation
sur le rapport des personnels qui
s'occupe de sécurité à la présidence de
la république et le ministère de
l'intérieur ou de la défense
il me semble que depuis le début de la
vème république
ces personnels appartiennent et sont
gérés par ces ministères qu'il ya donc
un lien y at il des cas où on imagine
dans des sociétés démocratiques ce lien
n'existe pas et peu quelle appréciation
auriez-vous sur une évolution de ce lien
dans le sens d'une plus grande autonomie
des personnels qui exercerait la
protection du président de la république
et sa sécurité
c'est vrai la sécurité d'un chef d'état
se gère toujours dans des configurations
qui sont propres à l'histoire de chaque
pays ou à l'évolution de cette histoire
au gouvernement le président des états
unis était protégé par une société
privée que ça peping cartonne après en
avoir perdu deux ou trois il a été
considéré plus utile de créer un service
le secretservice qui a deux missions la
protection du président des états unis
et la lutte contre la fausse monnaie
cet organisme est placé sous l'autorité
du secrétaire général
de la présidence enfin la maison blanche
mais avec une dépendance administrative
et fonctionnelle qui relève en partie du
département de la justice
en tout cas budgétaire mais c'est une
très grande autonomie
vous avez des régiments de garde
présidentielle dans beaucoup de pays et
des mercenaires et des sociétés privées
dans d'autres chacun fait un peu comme
il veut où comme il peut pour des
raisons qui sont liés à la confiance la
stabilité l'instabilité des dispositifs
de sécurité ou une longue tradition de
coup d'état ou le sergent-chef machin
remplaçait l'ancien caporal truc en
fonction de considérations locales ou ce
qui se passe dans notre ex empire
colonial montre une certaine forme
d'instabilité chronique mais le
commonwealth britannique a connu ces
mêmes difficultés c'est 1 1 restent mal
heureux de la manière dont la stabilité
de ces pays cette mise en place en
france
curieusement il y a d'abord un épisode
très instable qui est
entre la libération et 1958 où on passe
d'une absence d'organisation structurée
claire eua par l'institution garde
républicaine qui ressemble à l'outil de
protection des institutions il n'y a pas
d'outil véritablement clair autour du
général de gaulle et dans la partie qui
va aller jusqu'à la la fin des
événements d'algérie puisque la
détermination exacte de guerre d'algérie
semblait toujours complexe oui
il y à l'apparition d' unité
paramilitaire de dispositifs qui sont
pas tout à fait prévu par la
constitution ou la réglementation
ensuite on revient à une situation plus
républicaine au moment où la paix civile
s'installe jusqu'à 1983 et la création
du gspr qui a été au fil du temps plus
policiers que gendarme ou plus gendarmes
que policiers sous la même dénomination
quant au commandant militaire il
appartient à l'institution qui protège
tous les édifices publics et pour
prendre un exemple n'ai pas souvenir
qu'il ya un groupe de sécurité du
premier ministre qui pourrait
parfaitement se justifier dans le cadre
de l'organisation actuelle de la vème
république
parce que ça n'a pas semblé nécessaire
et pourtant le premier ministre est
aussi bien protégé je le pense que le
président de la république mais dans un
autre style de configuration les choix
qui peuvent être faits sont extrêmement
divers la mise en cohérence d'un outil
de sécurité est un enjeu majeur il est
assez difficile d'avoir un outil qui
s'occupe du fixe et un au cul d'un outil
qui s'occupe du mobile chacun sous un
chef différent et avec une organisation
complexe
enfin je précise que dans les missions
qui relèvent des responsables politiques
élus il ya plusieurs phases d'abord il
ya le fait de savoir qui les protègent
lorsqu'ils sont candidats et être
protégé par le ministre de l'intérieur
de la majorité sortante quand vous êtes
dans l'opposition est toujours un sujet
compliqué qui amène en général des
accommodements où on essaye de trouver
des policiers ou des gendarmes
républicain mais ayant une sorte d'
appartenance connu au camp d'en face
pour permettre à la fois que l'état
fasse son travail en protégeant les
candidats tout en faisant en sorte que
les candidats aient le sentiment d'être
en confiance et que les policiers ou les
gendarmes qui sont mis à leur
disposition ne fasse pas un rapport tous
les soirs au ministre de l'intérieur sur
tout ce qu'ils ont fait dit et pensé
durant la journée c'est un sujet de
confiance et donc il ya des
accommodements républicain relativement
connu d'ailleurs la presse se fait
l'écho de qui assume
la sécurité du candidat ou des candidats
de l'opposition en montrant bien que ça
s'est fait dans une sorte de de
cohérence générale ou qu'il ya un refus
d'ailleurs du candidat en question dont
je ne veux pas d'agent public parce que
je veux être sûr de mon entourage et il
ya donc des services d'ordre et les
organisations politiques disposent tout
syndical aussi d'ailleurs de service
d'ordre dont certains ont des missions
de protection rapprochée extrêmement
développée qu'on a d'ailleurs toujours
vu dans les campagnes présidentielle et
surtout pour les candidats les plus
exposés ou les plus à même de gagner
l'élection arrivé au pouvoir
la question se pose de la cohabitation
alors vous pouvez être nelson mandela
qui amène son unité de sécurité qui
vient directement de ce qu'on appelait
la lance de la nation le l'espace le
plus dur de la nc et qui explique aux
officiers bourg qui dirigeait le
gouvernement blanc et ségrégationniste
de suite que désormais ils feraient pays
fera cause commune
il faut être nelson mandela mais voilà
ça fonctionne et est donc il a intégré
ces unités un peu d'ailleurs comme
beaucoup d'officiers de la résistance se
sont trouvés intégrés dans les
institutions de l'état avec
reconnaissance de leurs titres gagnés
dans la clandestinité au moment où
l'état républicain s'est rétabli après
le régime de la collaboration
vous avez le processus de rebond bas
maintenant c'est fini donc on est dans
une logique d'état donc toi tu restes au
siège du parti est désormais
l'état république assume sa fonction
c'est le cas du secret de services
américains il n'y a pas de contractuels
de sécurité privée auprès du président
des états unis il n'y en a pas auprès du
premier de grande bretagne
il n'y en a pas auprès de la chancelière
d'allemagne je n'ai pas connaissance
qu'il y en ai d'ailleurs dans aucun des
pays de l'union européenne ayant un
régime
démocratique c'est il ya une stricte
séparation mais on peut avoir à son
cabinet au sens de l'appareil politique
quelqu'un qui s'occupe dans la partie
des déplacements de la partie on va dire
semi privé ou semi politique et qui a
une fonction ou simplement de lien local
qui peut exister mais les choses sont
clairement définis et déterminé et puis
vous avez des pays où c'est très
exactement l inverse le spoil system est
ainsi fait qu'en fait on ne fait
confiance à personne et donc une équipe
privée vient prendre le relais pour
assurer la sécurité est exact et
immédiate du chef de l'état ces choix
sont à la libre expression de nous
sommes une démocratie qu'à une vieille
histoire
je pense que la cohérence visant à ce
qu'il n'y ait que des agents publics
autour du président de la république
mais sous un commandement unique a du
sens parce que je vois pas très bien
comment on peut à la fois assurer la
sécurité résidentielle et la sécurité
des déplacements avec de commandement de
séparation deux unités mais c'est un
point de vue rationnel qui rentre pas
toujours en ligne de compte au moment où
on fait des choix plus personnel merci
de cette réponse monsieur bauer madame à
moins que monsieur sur est encore une
question non madame jourdain
c'est une question également d'ordre
gère comme celle de mon collègue
co-rapporteur vous indiquez à l'instant
et c'est exact que la sécurité ça sur
différemment selon l'histoire de chaque
pays alors ma question porte évidemment
sur sur la france et sur l'appréciation
que vous pouvez avoir du développement
des activités de sécurité privée et du
développement aussi des missions que le
pont confié aujourd'hui des agents de
sécurité privés bien le plus grand le
plus grand paradoxe de la situation
c'est que la sécurité privée résiste
avec détermination à la volonté de
l'état de lui confier des missions
toujours plus nombreuses et qui dépasse
très largement à la fois les limites que
le conseil des telles conséquences yen
ont rappelé à plusieurs reprises
je pense par tout particulièrement à la
voie publique et je pense spécifiquement
aux à la gare transfert et
hospitalisations des détenus l'état a
décidé depuis longtemps unilatéralement
alors il faut le savoir l'état a créé la
sécurité privée en france
c'est une action déterminée du préfet de
police de la seine
désormais paris qui a créé la première
société parisienne de surveillance qui
était une société avec des agents
supplétifs qui avaient des missions
assez spécifique sur les
les habitations bon marché ancêtres des
hlm et sur la mise en place d'outils de
transport qui est un peu compliquée qui
est-elle métropolitain parce que c'était
souterrain est un peu difficile à gérer
1900 rapport du préfet de la seine
devant le conseil municipal de paris
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
hélas mais en tout cas c'est comme ça et
donc ils avaient besoin d' agents
supplétifs et il s'est dit on va créer
une société parisienne de surveillance
qui permettra de recycler quelques
gardiens de la paix et surtout d'avoir
une espèce de force annexe pour
s'occuper de tout ce qui m'intéresse pas
vraiment et qui en général statique peu
dynamique et et
qu'ils n'avaient pas natale et aînés
ainsi l'histoire de la surveillance et
du gardiennage
les détectives c'est une histoire plus
ancienne dû essentiellement à l'action
de monsieur vidocq lui-même issu
contractuels de la sécurité publique de
la préfecture de police et qui
intervenait lui essentiellement sur la
fraude boursière car ça venait de se
développer
la police d'état n'en avait ni voyait
enfin comprenait pas ce que l'intérêt
que ça pouvait avoir les polices locales
encore moins il a trouvé un marché et
c'était le premier bureau du
renseignement universel et puis peu à
peu on a vu développé toute une série de
missions au fur et à mesure où l'état a
décidé de se retirer car en fait la
sécurité privée en france n'existe que
quand l'état se retire
l'état dit je ne veux plus assurer la
protection du transport de fonds bon eh
ben il faut bien que quelqu'un s'en
occupe
alors on demande à la poste de créer une
filiale qui vont ont dit les étrangers
vont peut-être enfin des étrangers ou
d'autres qui ont une spécificité l'ont
peut-être s'installer et donc la
sécurité et le transport de fonds
s'installe et ça fait donc désormais une
trentaine d'années qu'il y à des agents
de sécurité privés armés contrairement à
ce que tout le monde raconte plusieurs
milliers je précise d'ailleurs qu'il
n'ya aucune entre guillemets bavure
recensé de ses agents ils se font plus
souvent tiré dessus qu'il ne tire sur
des gens
notre cas ils sont présents ils sont là
et ça fait très longtemps
la troisième pack catégorie a étaient
les ports et transport il se trouve que
j'étais à l'époque avec michel rocard à
matignon et donc de loin ont prévu la
privatisation et la sous traitance du
contrôle et de la surveillance des
passagers et des bagages dans les ports
puis dans les aéroports puis élargie aux
ports maritimes 90 puis les stadiers
sont arrivés dans une configuration un
peu complexe et peu à peu l'état à créer
de nouveaux dispositifs
jusqu'au moment où il a imaginé qu'il
pouvait encore élargir le champ en
ouvrant par exemple la garde armée des
navires a la garde a remis des navires
se fait hors territoire national mais
pose des problèmes qui était que les
navires français n'était donc plus
gardés par des anglo saxons avec les
problématiques de souveraineté que ça
c'est une partie importante de la flotte
ensuite c'est poser le problème des
gardes armés
le préfet c'est laid était optimiste en
disant que c'était interdit puisque la
créativité bureaucratique du ministère
de l'intérieur a été sans limites
puisque si les gardes armés étaient
interdits dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions d'agents de protection
rapprochée il avait le droit de porter
une arme car le simple fait qu'il soit à
côté d'une cible les autoriser a demandé
larmes pour eux parce qu'ils étaient à
côté de la personne qu'ils devaient
protéger et donc en fait il y avait une
centaine de personnes qui étaient armés
en france dans des conditions de
légalité extrêmement contestable et
c'est après laffaire charlie hebdo que
le gouvernement a décidé de sortir de
l'ambiguïté du bricolage et de ce qui
était toléré y compris pour des
accompagnants de personnalités
étrangères qui n'étaient pas eux mêmes
agents publics et donc hors des
conventions internationales diplomatique
de protection des dirigeants en visite
qui a permis de sortir de ce flou et de
cette ambiguïté avec le fameux texte qui
va enfin prochainement entrer en
application
de la même manière il existe des gardes
armés sur des entreprises d'état qui
sont désormais soumis privatisée et qui
pour des raisons de souveraineté
nationale ou dangereux comme le
nucléaire par exemple le protègent
certaines installations
donc il ya un grand bricolage qui a été
fait tout ça appartient à un espace où
il ya une sorte de consensus général sur
les limites de l'exercice
là où il n'y a pas consensus et où
l'état est souvent demandeurs dans des
conditions qui me paraît
extraordinairement dangereuse c'est la
protection de la voie publique et la
garde le transfert et le spi tation des
détenus et tout ce qui relève de
l'administration pénitentiaire ce sont
des pulsions que je dont j'espère
qu'elles sont résistible mais qui
prennent régulièrement l'état qui a une
vision assez large de tous de ce dont il
pourrait se débarrasser au bénéfice de
la sécurité privée et je tiens à dire
dont le collège du cnaps en tout cas
avec les représentations de toutes les
orientations prochaine a déjà expliqué à
plusieurs reprises à l'unanimité qu'il
n'en voulait pas merci beaucoup monsieur
grosdidier mois que pardon monsieur
monsieur sur un propos du port d'armes
vous paraît-il justifier que parmi le
personnel de l'elysée titulaires ou
contractuels d'autres personnes que
celles appartenant au commandement
militaire et au gspr soit détenteur d'un
port d'armes
un variateur réponse à votre question la
première réponse et n'importe qui peut
demander un port d'armes
n'importe qui voilà donc c'est un sujet
qui nécessite de revoir la question du
port d'armes au sens de l'appréciation
personnelle qui est fait à chaque
demande individuelle le port d'armes de
manière opérationnelle le plus sûr moyen
d'avoir un accident un assassinat ou une
bavure c'est de créer des commandements
différents avec des individus
appartenant à des chaînes différentes
ayant des pratiques différentes une
formation différente une compétence
différentes au même endroit tous avec
des moyens létaux donc la réponse est à
titre individuel je vois aucune autre
difficulté que l'appréciation qui est
fait d'une demande personnelle pour
dames à titre opérationnel la réponse et
il ne peut y avoir et il ne doit y avoir
qu'un seul opérateur une seule chaîne de
commandement et un seul dispositif à la
fois de formation de connaissance de
confiance de réactivité et donc il est
clair que pour la deuxième partie la
réponse est non d'évaluation et de
coordination
je remercie monsieur power est
effectivement là c'est pas si vous avez
regardé toutes les auditions mais cela
donne à réfléchir
relativement à votre réalisation unité
dans la chaîne de commandement
c'est tout
c'est un commentaire alors monsieur
grosdidier vous êtes un spécialiste du
droit comparé et aussi un observateur
des différents dispositifs existants par
le monde vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs
de ce que ça pouvait dans des
démocraties balbutiantes ou dans des
régimes des régimes autoritaires et et
instable mais y at il des exemples dans
les grandes démocraties bien installé
ancien de dispositifs de sécurité du
président complètement dissociés il ya
des forces qui normalement relève du
gouvernement et même pouvant échapper à
l'état de droit je veux dire je
m'explique on en a eu un
un exemple d'autonomisation complète du
de la protection du président à l'égard
du mystère de l'intérieur lors des
dérives dire de ces gendarmes qui à
l'époque est à indienne se permettait
même s'autoriser même des écoutes
téléphoniques
et quand elles étaient commandés pouvait
invoquer le régime d'immunité du
président de la république dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
donc si serre nous respectons tous la
séparation des pouvoirs nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit respectée à
l'égard du parlement
est ce que au nom de leurs principes
démocratiques anciens de la séparation
des pouvoirs
on peut justifier une séparation au sein
de l'exécutif entre la sécurité
présidentielle et celles relevant du
gouvernement et notamment du ministère
de l'intérieur d'ailleurs avec elle un
projet d'autonomisation complète de la
sécurité élyséenne à l'égard du mime du
ministère de l'intérieur de même façon
et ce qu'on peut contester fait pour le
parlement qui dans toutes les
démocraties contrôle les services de
sécurité lui contester le droit de de
contrôle également la sécurité de la
présenter république oued qu'en est il
en droit comparé et ce que ce serait
s'il était confirmé en france peu une
singularité française que d'avoir un
système de protection lycéens qui
échappe aux usa de l'intérieur et est
une cause et une impossibilité pour le
parlement de contrôler
la sécurité de la présidence de la
république
j'aimerais la possibilité éventuelle
d'une cohabitation s'est beaucoup
réduite d'après les constitutionnalistes
au moment où il y a eu la confusion des
deux élections dans un délai rapproché
dans le même temps la dissolution d'une
chambre n'est pas impossible et le fait
qu'il y ait un président d'une couleur
et un gouvernement ou une majorité
parlementaire du nôtre est une
possibilité la question est est-ce qu'il
s'agit dans ce cas précis d'un risque
pour que l'autorité présidentielle soit
combattue par un ministère de
l'intérieur - républicains qu'il ne l'a
été jusqu'à présent je rappelle que lors
des périodes de cohabitation le choix du
ministre de l'intérieur faisait l'objet
d'un dosage extraordinairement
particulier
nonobstant la réalité du résultat de
l'élection législative ou de la majorité
des deux chambres donc on sent bien
qu'il y a là une sensibilité
particulière alors quand on respecte les
statuts du président a répliqué du
premier ministre dont le niveau
d'équivalence reste fort
on peut arriver à s'en sortir s'il ya un
conflit majeur
l'idée que la sécurité du chef de l'état
chef des armées et par ailleurs ayant
désormais des pouvoirs relativement
élargie notamment avec la création du
conseil de sécurité intérieure sur
proposition du préfet maccioni et sous
leur décision du président chirac montre
qu'on est quand même dans un espace un
peu compliqué moi je suis très partisans
du contrôle
ça me paraît être une nécessité
parlementaire contrôle budgétaire
contrôle effectif du point de vue de
l'autonomie et de l'indépendance de la
capacité du président de la république
lorsqu'il n'est pas en situation de
majorité parlementaire mais qu'il est
toujours le président de l'apic choisi
au suffrage universel
le fait qu'il y ait là un effort de
compréhension particulière me semble
raisonnablement compréhensible il l'a
été jusqu'à présent sans obligation de
modifier les textes mais chacun se
rappelle que le gps air sous jacques
chirac n'est pas le même que sous
françois mitterrand il n'est pas non
plus le même sous nicolas sarkozy et la
configuration actuelle montre qu'il
n'est pas non plus voilà il donc il ya
des modalités d assouplissement des
complexités qu'il faut prendre en
considération ce qui m'amène à dire que
plutôt que d'attendre le moment de la
crise pour gérer ce problème à la
française c'est toujours au moment où
alors qu'on aurait pu le faire bien
avant de manière calme et tranquille
peut-être le moment est effectivement
venu de mettre à plat la manière dont
fonctionne un service de la sécurité
présidentielle mais comme je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure la question se pose aussi
d'une manière différente pour le premier
espace caprio il est le chef de la
majorité et on peut considérer qu'il
n'aura pas les mêmes relations avec son
ministre de l'intérieur que le président
de la république dans le cas d'une
cohabitation dans tout état de cause le
fait de remettre à plat des dispositifs
qui ont vieilli et qui sont plus tout à
fait adaptées aux problématiques par
exemple des drones aux problématiques de
la modification de la troisième
dimension de la sécurité d'un espace qui
a beaucoup changé sur le cyber notamment
ça mériterait une remise en place et je
pense d'ailleurs que de ce point de vue
là c'est autant au parlement qu'à
l'exécutif de remettre à plat les
dispositifs de sécurité des institutions
de la république certainement
monsieur madame merci monsieur le
président monsieur le professeur
je m'adresse au criminologue vous avez
comme nous vu cette photo de monsieur
benalla avec l' arme au poing
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous inspire
cette attitude de quelqu'un qui se dit
un professionnel de la sécurité
et est-ce qu'un tel comportement est
fréquent j'ai rarement vu des scènes
fille de campagne où on essaie
d'impressionner la serveuse avec un
glock je dois dire que c'est plutôt une
nouveauté les réseaux sociaux sont
passés par là
d'un point de vue professionnel
c'est contraire à l'ensemble des règles
de porc d'usagé et de maniement des
armes donc de celui là il n'y a pas
photo s'ils passaient un examen ils
auraient zéro et le 0 2 point de vue là
est plutôt une note éliminatoire
peut-être ajouter que ça n'est pas légal
de porter une arme dans les conditions
dans laquelle il apportait alors à ce
moment précis son autorisation d'après
ce que j'en sais ne le permettait pas
donc là je suis entré sur le domaine
purement prochain je n'ai pas géré la
partie légale mais il semble qu
effectivement l'autorisation dont il
disposait à l'époque ne lui permettait
pas non seulement de l'exhiber mais
encore moins de la portée et bien s'il
n'y a pas d'autres questions je vois
qu'il n'y en a pas d'autres monsieur
bord il me reste à vous remercier
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage à notre
commission
la séance est levée mais chers collègues
pour l'audition d'alain bauer
criminologue ancien directeur du cnams
que vous avez pu suivre en direct sur
l'antenne de public sénat on voit bien
sûr revenir sur ces auditions ce matin
avec vous benjamin morel qu'avez vous
pensé de cette dernière audition on voit
d'un côté et les sénateurs qui cherche
toujours à comprendre le rôle qu'a pu
avoir alexandre bédat là je le disais
oui c'était une audition un peu on va
dire à double
double double volume d'une certaine
façon on n'auditionnait certes le prêt
l'ancien président du cnaps il ya eu des
questions qui ont été posées sur le
cnaps mais auquel du coup l'audition
précédentes avaient déjà permis
d'apporter quelques réponses
même s'il ya pu avoir quelques
conceptions divergentes entre les deux
auditions et ensuite et bien alain bauer
c'est également le grand spécialiste de
la sécurité le grand criminologue et
donc on a demandé à alain bauer ce qu'il
pensait de l'organisation de la sécurité
du président de la république et du rôle
que pour qu'ils pouvaient être celui
d'alexandre benalla sur la question du
cnaps eh bien il a plutôt charest tenté
de défendre le cnaps de dia n'y avait
pas eu d'erreur à ce niveau là sur le
rôle d'alexandre benalla là il a été
beaucoup plus critiques tout en
réinterrogeant de façon globale le
fonctionnement de la sécurité du
président la garde rapprochée du
président ne peut pas relever secteur
privé alors il a dit deux choses il a
dit d'abord ça ne peut pas relever du
secteur privé ça ne peut pas inclure des
agents contractuels ce qui est un peu
reproché à alexandre benalla et ce n'est
le cas dans aucune des grandes
démocraties occidentales
donc en sous main il a cité un certain
nombre de régimes qui n'était pas
démocratique et qui employé ce type de
procédé donc là on voit tout de même en
filigrane une attaque assez dur sur ce
type de pratique quand même temps il a
dit eh bien il faut malgré tout que ce
soit organisé qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule
tête qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule chaîne
de commandement sinon ça fonctionne mal
donc il faut que le serment alors tel
qu'on peut l'entendre en tout cas ils
visent ni l'un ni l'autre il vise la
division d2 il vise justement la
séparation entre ces deux organes et il
plaide pour un rapprochement mais un
rapprochement dans les mains du public
dans les mains d'une certaine façon est
bien de fonctionnaires compétents de
fonctionnaires à gré de fonctionnaires
choisi est responsable au regard de leur
statut ou car c'est ce à quoi peut être
réfléchi c'est alexandre benalla en tous
les cas ça a été annoncé comme tel est
confirmée
dans l'entretien qu'il avait accordé
avec son journal le monde sait ça c'est
à dire que d'une certaine façon si on
peut considérer qu alexandre bauer porte
un regard sur l'action d'alexandre
benalla c'est un regard ambigu
l'ambition qui est prêtée alexandre
benalla même s'il a nié qu'ils étaient
de réorganiser est une bonne ambitions
en revanche le statut d' alexandre
benalla ne lui permettaient clairement
pas selon alain bauer d'occuper ce type
de fonction et d'avoir ce type
d'ambition alors il ya cette dernière
question sur ce seul fille qui a été
révélé avant-hier par mediapart on sait
depuis que le parquet de poitiers a
ouvert une enquête judiciaire à
l'encontre d'alexandre benalla là encore
les commentaires et bien d'aller voir
les commentaires de l'aude alain bauer
sont sans appel d'abord il n'a pas tous
les éléments en main mais il considère
est en effet c'est le cas que si jamais
il n'y avait pas d'autorisation et que
cette photo a bien été prise au moment
auquel on dit qu'elle a été prise et
bien alexandre benalla était dans
l'illégalité et au delà de ça du point
de vue de l'éthique de la profession
comme il l'a dit lui-même c'est un zéro
pointé
donc là il y a un problème d'incarnation
il ya un problème légal
il a dessus alain bauer est extrêmement
clair cette photo met en évidence aussi
peut-être des contradictions sur les
propos tenus à sous serment devant une
commission d' enquête parlementaire
ce matin à les sénateurs interrogé par
les journalistes de public sénat
n'excluait pas potentiellement une
nouvelle audition
on sait que ça mettait le cas à
l'assemblée nationale avec qu'à
l'audition d'alain gibelin il était
revenu sur ses propos
alors ça peut interroger en effet sur la
sincérité ou la mémoire d'alexandre
benalla lorsqu'il a témoigné la semaine
dernière après faut-il organiser une
nouvelle audition ou simplement
constater qu'il ya mensonge
de fait on voit mal comment alexandre
benalla et bien pourrait éclairer plus
cette situation alors que la très
clairement il a été pris un peu en
flagrant délit d'imprécisions war de
mensonges le sénateur et l'ère françois
grosdidier le d
non seulement alexandre mais n'a à mon
team et il n'est pas le seul
ça relève du par jour ça benjamin morel
ça relève du parjure sauf si vous ne
saviez pas quand on parle d' avec son
bel anna là on parle de quelqu'un qui
par définition ce avait ensuite les
autres acteurs qui ont pu intervenir eux
peuvent être fondés à dire bah je
n'avais pas vu cette photo il s'en est
il s'est servi de son arme à ce moment
là mais je n'en avais pas connaissance
concernant alexandre benalla on est dans
quelque chose en effet qui pose beaucoup
plus problème est là bas il ya des
mécanismes éventuel de franck de
sanctions en cas de parjure et si jamais
le sénat veut aller plus loin et bien
théoriquement il pourrait au fur et à
mesure des auditions on voit qu
alexandre benalla visiblement exercer
une mission de police de sécurité de
garde rapprochée auprès d'emmanuel
macron ça a été rappelé 1 par le préfet
michel bénard qui en tant qu'ancien
directeur du gie espère assurer à la
sécurité et de nicolas sarkozy pour lui
et bien le port d'armes est réservé aux
forces de sécurité intérieure
oui et l'audition d'alain bauer en bois
un peu la même chose également c'est à
dire que la sécurité du président de la
république doit être confiée à des
fonctionnaires qui peuvent porter une
arme
dès lors que vous avez un agents non
fonctionnaires qui intervient qui porte
une arme
il est au mieux quelque chose qui
interroge et qui apparaît comme une
nuisance dans la chaîne de commandement
qui crée plus de questions qu autre
chose
au pire même comme une menace parce que
du coup c'est quelqu'un qui met en
danger la cohérence du dispositif et du
coup devient un élément problématique
donc là on voit que la présence
d'alexandre benalla avec une arme dans
l'entourage des manuels macron est au
mieux et bien quelque chose qui n'avait
pas lieu d'être
au pire quelque chose qui remettait en
cause en fait le fonctionnement général
de la sécurité du président dans tous
les cas on est face à un problème
justement j'ai mal je vous proposerai
goûter est les propos du préfet michel
bénard sur cette question du port d'armé
et quand je vois l'image du
président macron avec monsieur benalla
proximité il m'est difficile de dire
s'il est présent à ses côtés en tant que
membre de son cabinet vous membres de sa
sécurité pour pouvoir vous répondre
il faudrait que une action se déroule à
savoir qu'il fallait opérer une
évacuation du président de la république
pour voir à ce moment là qu'ils
agiraient et que ferais tu il
aujourd'hui
la présence à proximité immédiate du
président la réplique d'un certain
nombre de passes de personne ne peut pas
déterminer un coup sur son rôle
je vous ai cité toutes les personnes qui
prouve qu'on pouvait trouver dans
l'environnement immédiat du président de
la république qui rentre dans le cercle
que j'ai évoqués on y trouve aussi ce
que j'appelle moi des parasites des gens
qui sont des courtisans et qu'on trouve
à proximité de président de la
république est qu eux constitue une gêne
qui nous appartient de d'évacuer parfois
d'éloigner pour pouvoir exercer cette
fonction
ces propos on va retrouver aux côtés de
philippe le président de cette
commission enquête sénatoriale
oui philippe bas quels enseignements
tirez-vous et bien des auditions de ce
matin notamment de celle du préfet
bénard qui a dit que eh bien il n'avait
jamais eu connaissance de personnes en
dehors du gspr ou du commandant
militaire qui avait une arme au sein du
palais de l'elysée et encore moins pour
se protéger elle même
oui fait nous nous attendions à cette
réponse
en vérité ce qui s'est produit ces
derniers mois et est assez singulier
qu'un membre du cabinet du président de
la république soit armé qu'il accompagne
le président de la république en
occupant une place à l'épaule comme on
dit dans le jargon technique de la
sécurité c'est quelque chose de très
singulier et nous avons posé la question
à monsieur bénard de savoir si cette
position a pu altérer la bonne
organisation de la sécurité nous a fait
une réponse prudente comme il se devait
il n'a pas connu ce type d'expérience
mais il est certain que le groupe de
sécurité du président de la république a
dû s'adapter à cette particularité
qu'on peut même qualifier de singularité
quand on regarde l'histoire de la
protection du président de la république
et qu'on l'élargît même à l'observation
de la sécurité du premier ministre
puisque monsieur bénard a aussi était le
responsable de la sécurité de deux
premiers ministres qu'il a et l'autre
d'ailleurs
edouard balladur et lionel jospin ont
été candidats à la présidence de la
république il a donc une très grande
expérience
nous voulions que ce soit technique
parce que nous voulons savoir exactement
de quoi nous parlons
et ça a été technique c'est très
important pour nous que cette exigence
de précision soit soit respecté mais en
même temps vous l'avez dit michel bénard
a été prudent il l'a dit cette position
que peu à voir alexandre benalla à
l'égard du président de la république ne
qualifie pas forcément sale d'un
officier de sécurité que cela pouvait
bien être est bien celle d'un membre de
cabinets membres de cabinets peut-être
gênant pour le j'espère oui en fait de
deux choses l'une ou bien il est à
l'épaule sans assurer la sécurité ça
complique la sécurité ou bien l'êta
l'épaule pour assurer la sécurité et
alors là c'est la compliquent aussi dans
la mesure où il n'a pas l'appartenance
au groupe de sécurité du président de la
république qui est sélectionné évalué
entraîné coordonnées dans un cadre
collectif
donc vous voyez que dans les deux cas
c'est une complication
au lieu d'être un avantage et au fond il
est trop tôt nous pour livrer des
conclusions il faut qu'on en délibère
nous avons écrit pour avoir dans tous
les grands pays démocratiques des
éléments sur la manière dont la sécurité
des chefs de gouvernement et chef d'état
est assurée nous avons demandé des
informations complémentaires
un certain nombre de personnes
auditionnées par des lettres que nous
avons écrit nous recueillons toute cette
information qui s'ajoutent aux auditions
près de trente déjà de sorte que ensuite
la commission des lois sur le rapport de
nos deux rapporteurs muriel jourda et
jean pierre sueur puisse délibérer deux
propositions nous n'avons qu'une idée en
tête faire en sorte que la cinquième
puissance du monde la france assure pour
son président de la république son
premier ministre
la sécurité maximale une dernière
question à ce que vous souhaitez
entendre à nouveau alexandre benalla au
vu des contradictions atteint avec les
différents témoignages notamment après
la publication de cette photo par b par
mediapart
hier on le voit une arme à la main
pendant la campagne présidentielle alors
qu'il avait dit ne pas avoir eu
d'autorisation de port d'armes à cette
époque je comprends le trouble que jette
cette information est d'ailleurs vous
avez appris comme moi qu'une enquête
judiciaire a été ouverte sur ce point
car s'il s'agissait bien d'une arme
opérationnel
à l'évidence il n'avait pas à la porté
pendant la campagne présidentielle
et si même il avait été autorisé à le
faire
cette forme d'exhibition est quelque
chose qui peut effectivement choquer le
public est choqué évidemment les
représentants de la nation que nous
sommes mais je tiens à vous dire que il
s'agit d'éléments qui font l'objet
maintenant d'une enquête judiciaire
je n'ai donc pas auditionner monsieur
benalla pour l'interroger sur son
comportement parce que je sortirai à ce
moment-là du mandat qui m'a été donné à
l'unanimité qui a été donné à la
commission des lois à l'unanimité par le
sénat le 23 juillet dernier pour
enquêter sur les conditions dans
lesquelles des personnes étrangères aux
forces de sécurité peuvent contribuer à
des opérations de sécurité et à la
protection de hautes personnalités
ça n'est pas le même sujet les relations
sont plus apaisée avec l'exécutif sur ce
sujet on a entendu nicole belloubet à
que vous aviez auditionné hier bien à
dire qu'elle respectait le travail de la
commission denquête vous réjouissez de
cela après l'aller les mots qui s était
échangé la semaine dernière vous savez
je ne me préoccupe pas de ce que disent
tel ou tel sauf pour me réjouir des
propos que vous venez de citer
nous avons fait notre travail je
l'espère sérieusement je crois que ceux
qui l'ont suivi peuvent témoigner de
l'impression qu'ils auront tu de notre
travail et nous avons évité d'être
attentif aux bruits de fond à une forme
de nervosité que n'en a pu constater
même parfois de fébrilité il n'y a pas
de raison que nous changions d'attitude
parce que le ton s'est enfin adouci
beaucoup philippe bas d'avoir répondu à
mes questions merci merci à vous à table
pour toutes à ces précisions benjamin
morel c'est vrai qu'on parlait de
socialisme ça fait désormais l'objet
d'une enquête judiciaire
on se souvient des précautions prises
par les sénateurs à lorsqu'ils ont
auditionné les annales a mis en examen
on ne peut pas finalement l'auditionner
sur cette photo il est vrai qu'on ne
peut absolument pas l'auditionner dès
lors que
une enquête judiciaire est en cours il
n'y a pas la possibilité sauf à
contrevenir à la séparation des pouvoirs
et bien d'auditionner alexandre benalla
pour ce fait donc il est toujours
possible d'auditionner alexandre benalla
mais si jamais il est à nouveau
auditionnés eh bien on ne pourrait pas
l'interroger sur cette fameuse soirée où
il portait une arme
du coup l'intérêt de l'audition est
limité en revanche ça n'empêche pas de
poursuivre éventuellement alexandre
benalla pour parjure si jamais la
commission denquête le souhaitent
là c'est une autre question mais en
revanche une audition qui aborderait ce
sujet serait une audition qui ré contre
la séparation des pouvoirs
on a entendu philippe bas précisé
rappeler 1 quels étaient les objectifs
poursuivis par cette commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale c'est faire la
lumière sur l'organisation de la
sécurité présidentielle est ce qu'il ya
des nouveaux éléments ce matin qui sont
apparus notamment lors de l'audition
d'alain bauer sur peut-être serait bien
une dualité on l'évoqué entoure le
j'espère le commandement militaire en
tout cas le besoin peut-être de herat
organiser les choses est ce que c'est
encore adapté finalement aussi cette
organisation aux présidentielles oui
alain bauer n'a pas forcément apporté
beaucoup sur cette question d' éléments
de fait c'est à dire que sur les faits
comment est-ce que ça se passe il nous a
pas appris grand chose qu'on ne savait
déjà
en revanche il nous a apporté des
éléments d analyse est en effet ce qu'il
dit c'est que grosso modo la dualité
pose problème la dualité et bien et plus
source de complexité et d'interrogations
qu'autre chose et en revanche et dualité
peut-être doit-elle disparaître mais si
elle disparaît elle doit disparaître au
profit du d'un fonctionnement
publiquement fonctionnement tenu par
l'état et là encore une fois il a repris
il a refait le panorama des grandes
démocraties occidentales pour nous
expliquer bien comment ça pouvait
fonctionner aux etats-unis en
grande-bretagne en allemagne et caetera
et au bout du compte vous dire que
l'unité et le caractère public et bien
ça représentait les deux grands piliers
de la sécurité des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dans les pays démocratiques
et que ce n'était pas tout à fait pour
rien à la fois pour garantir la
démocratie et pour garantir leur
caractère fonctionnel alors benjamin
aura le voit c'est avec nous on continue
à les réactions assez à trois auditions
ce matin à tain de tran huy
côté sénateur socialiste du loiret jean
pierre sueur qui est rapporteur de cette
commission enquête
oui jean pierre sueur que retenez-vous
de cette matinée d'audition et notamment
de la première audition celle de michel
bénard on a appris et bien que le fait
que alexandre benalla est un port
d'armes au sein de l'elysée était tout à
fait inédit oui nous avons entendu trois
personnes nouvelles on doit arriver à
une trentaine d'auditions maintenant et
c'était très intéressant sur le plan
technique
voyez vous certains croient que nous
cherchons le sensationnel non nous
sommes là pour trouver la vérité pour
trouver les dysfonctionnements quand
même on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
de dysfonctionnement et pour en tirer
les conséquences et faire des
propositions
bon il est certain que monsieur bénard
qui a bien connu le gs père puisqu'il
l'a le groupe de sécurité du président
de la république visibles a pu nous dire
sous différents dans différents
contextes cohabitation etc a pu nous
dire clairement comment à son avis ça
devait fonctionner eux quels étaient les
rapports avec le commandement militaire
quels étaient les rapports avec les
autorités de l'elysée le ministère de
l'intérieur je l'interrogeais là-dessus
clairement et a dit clairement que à sa
connaissance vous rendez compte
jamais pendant qu'il était en fonction
personne
on lui a fait répéter personne en dehors
des gens du groupement de sécurité de la
présidence de la république et du
commandement militaire personne n'avait
de port d'armes
donc la situation de monsieur ben ali
ben alla apparaît assez atypique et nous
poursuivons inlassablement notre travail
avec le second d'interlocuteurs monsieur
seul et le fait qu'ils disent qu'ils
n'aient jamais été garde du corps est ce
que pour vous vous prenez ce qui dit
lorsqu'il dit eh bien c'est nous allons
faire son come et comme peuvent faire
tous les citoyens qui ont pu écouter
qu'ils peuvent
regardez en podcast l'ensemble des 30
audition
je sais qu'il y a des jeunes qui en ont
fait un jeu pour voir tout cela comme un
écheveau vous savez un jeu de piste
essayer de comprendre
je vous assure que lorsque l'on regarde
toutes ses auditions il y a un nombre
considérable de contradictions
d'imprécisions de non dits et nous nous
allons faire notre travail correctement
on va tout mettre à plat et on pourra
faire des conclusions on le dire à ce
moment là ce que nous voulons c'est
connaître la vérité et il est certain
qu'il y a des faits extrêmement
troublant et parce qu'il ya des
déclarations mais vraiment très
différentes
vous savez aujourd'hui on reprendrait
les déclarations du secrétaire général
de l'elysée du directeur de cabinet de
l'élysée on trouverait quand même qu'il
y à un certain nombre de nouvelles
déclarations qui je ne porte pas de
jugement mais ne sont pas en raccord ne
sont pas en accord ou en raccord et d'où
les contradictions donc contradictions
généralisée vous ne pouvez pas ré
entendre tout le monde car vous n'avez
pas fermé la porte au fait d'entendre à
nouveau alexandre bédat la cave où
l'image est là la commission peut
décider d'entendre tout le monde de
réentendre tout le monde sauf le
président de la république bien sûr et
la commission peut aussi décider ce que
nous faisons largement d'écrire à
différentes personnes et notamment aux
personnes auditionnées pour obtenir des
précisions et des documents et les
preuves
donc nous avons ce pouvoir et nous en
faisons
et puis il ya des faits qui apparaît
sous les jours par cette photo sur
laquelle villa marie mercier a interrogé
alain bauer
cette photo publiée par mediapart dont
naturellement nous n'avons pas grand
chose à dire sinon que comme tout
citoyen
nous sommes étonnés c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
philippe bas a dit à votre antenne que
puisque je crois le procureur de la
république de poitiers a ouvert une
preuve une enquête préliminaire
ça relève désormais de la justice donc
ça ne fait pas partie de notre champ
c'est la constitution et maintenant je
crois que aucun ministre nous rappelle
le chaque matin chaque midi chaque soir
la constitution parce qu ils se sont
rendus compte que c'était inutile
puisque non seulement nous la
connaissons mais nous la pratiquant donc
la justice va traiter de ce fait mais ce
fait est quand même extrêmement choquant
et je pense que les français qu'ils
apprennent ne peuvent pas quand même
trouvé ce comportement normal monsieur
bauer a dit que c'était vraiment
totalement inadmissible sur le plan tout
simplement de la déontologie
merci beaucoup gens bien sûr pour votre
réaction et à bientôt
merci à vous tam pour ses réactions en
direct dans un bras longs continuent et
d'analysé à ces auditions ce matin de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale a été
rappelé et une situation finalement
particulièrement atypique un cette
position de alexandre benalla sur sa
fonction on voit clairement des
contradictions qui apparaissent on l'a
redit sur cette question du port d'armes
c'est la première fois finalement qu'un
adjoint au chef de cabinet étaient armés
oui en tout cas selon exxon alexandre
benalla il ya pu y en avoir d'autres
mais d'après ce que nous disent les
auditionner de ce matin c'est quelque
chose d'assez inédit et ça renvoie en
fait tous deux grandes questions qui
ressort de ces auditions aujourd'hui la
première c'est qu'elle fonctions
occupées alexandre benalla à c'est à
cette question là on n'a pas toujours de
réponse claire alexandre reynal à nous
d'y jeter dans un rôle seulement
d'organisation d'autres auditionné nous
disent ça ne peut pas être un rôle
d'organisation c'est forcément un rôle
opérationnel
et la question qui arrivent ensuite qui
est subséquentes et que la deuxième
grande question c'est celle en effet du
port d'armes
alexandre benalla pouvait qu il portait
une arme dans quel cadre porter une arme
et dans quels cas de lui at on accorder
le droit de porter une arme
à ces deux questions pour l'instant on
n'a pas de réponse claire on a des sons
de cloches extrêmement différents avec
des professionnels qui nous disent ils
ne pouvaient pas avoir d'action
opérationnel il ne pouvait pas non plus
naître que dans l'organisation elle au
vu de ce qu'il faisait
qu'ils nous disent il ne peut pas avoir
de fond qui ne qui nous disent qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas avoir de fonctions de
police et en même temps que sans
fonction de police il ne pouvait pas
avoir d'armes
donc là il ya encore beaucoup de choses
qui sont extrêmement floues
beaucoup de zones d'ombré et les
auditions de ce matin et bien en fait
n'ont fait que confirmer l'existence de
zones d'ombré n'ont fait que confirmer
le fait qu'il y a des choses et bien que
l'on n'arrive pas tout à fait à
déterminer ni à comprendre dans la
sécurité présidentielle pour autant les
travaux de la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale pourrait à toucher
prochainement à leur faim avec
l'audition programmé à la semaine
prochaine de l'ancienne directrice du
j'espère sophie atsem qui s'occupait de
la sécurité de françois hollande
avec le recul on le disait ça va quand
même permettre bien de mettre la lumière
sur ce fonctionnement sur cette
organisation de la sécurité
présidentielle
alors oui ça va tout de même permettre
c'est à dire qu'il ya deux choses qui
ressort de ces auditions si on veut
jouer un peu les chercheurs il ya d'un
côté les dysfonctionnements qui sont des
dysfonctionnements conjoncturel lié sans
doute à la personnalité d'alexandre
benalla et la mise en place d'une
administration relativement rapide et
c'est bon ça c'est quelque chose que
normalement devrait arriver à décrire la
commission denquête en constatant le
fait qu'il n'ait qui des zones d'ombré
et du simple fait qu'il y ait des zones
d'ombré c'est déjà un constat
intéressant
ensuite le deuxième point c'est qu'en
effet on a appris beaucoup grâce à cette
affaire sur la faune que sur la façon
dont fonctionne la sécurité
présidentielle et dont on pourrait être
dont elle pourrait être amélioré
l'analyse d'alain bauer ce matin était
pour sa intéressante on voit que au delà
même du cas benalla au delà même de la
presse de la présente présidence eh bien
il ya une marge d'amélioration
il ya des choses qui pourraient mieux
fonctionner il y à des choix qui peut
être dans les années sud dans les années
prochaines doivent être faites et on
attend effectivement à les
préconisations les recommande
a sion à des sénateurs sur ces points
évoqués merci à vous merci à nous avoir
accompagnés ce matin c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir toutes
ses auditions sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous donne rendez vous à 16h30 pour
une nouvelle édition de ses vins 360 on
reviendra bien entendu sur ces travaux
parlementaires à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment